SENATE COUNTER WHICH IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SEVEN SIXTY
TWO AND WILL TAKE THIS UP ONCE
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM SO --
AGAIN OF SUBBING FOR VICE CHAIR
BOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL IS
HERE SO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL -- SO
WILL FIRST TAKE UP --
SENATOR EFFORTS BIG SENATOR
HERTZBERG HIS BILL WHICH IS S.
B..
NINE THIRTY OF FIRST THIS
MORNING AND PRESENTING FOR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR HERTZBERG IS A
FREDDIE CAN TANA.
AT AS WELL AS BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER.
FEW IN A MALL AND AGAIN THIS IS
S. B..
NINE THIRTY F. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. --
NINE THIRTY HIS KATANA FILL
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ASSN HERTZBERG REGRETS
THEY CANNOT PRESENT THIS MORNING
BUT HE APPRECIATES THAT YOU WORK
WITH US ON THE MEASURE HERE --
IN THE FIRST TWO MONTHS OF DON'T
USE CANNABIS LEGISLATION
CONSUMERS BOUGHT AN ESTIMATED
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
MILLION WORTH OF MARIJUANA
PRODUCTS IN THE FIRST QUARTER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE STATE
COLLECTED OVER SIXTY MILLION.
IN TAX REVENUES WHILE THESE
FIGURES WERE LOWER THAN EXPECTED
IS STILL AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
CASH TO MANAGE.
AND THIS CASH INFUSED INDUSTRY
HAS PRESENTED A PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE THEY HAVE ALSO THEIR BEEN
SEVERAL INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHERE INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN ROBBED A OF
CASH OF CASH IN PRODUCTS.
AS POLICY MAKERS THERE'S A DUTY
TO FURTHER THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS WHILE PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND BY CREATING A
PATH FOR THESE LIMITED CHARTER
BANKS WE ARE FULFILLING THIS
DUTY.
WITH US HERE TODAY AS PART OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER FIONA MA THE
SPONSOR OF A BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS --
UNDER PROP TWO FIFTEEN PASSED
TWENTY YEARS AGO OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION WAS AUTHORIZED TO
COLLECT SALES TAXES FROM THE
DISPENSARIES.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
AND STATE CONFLICT OF THE BOARD
NEVER REALLY COLLECTED IT UNTIL
ABOUT --
NINETEEN NINETY SIX IT HAS BEEN
A REAL STRUGGLE FOR THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
UP BUT WHEN --
I GOT ELECTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
I ASKED THE BOARD TO TELL US HOW
MUCH.
A WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING FROM THE
DISPENSARIES SO BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE COLLECTED ABOUT
FORTY NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF FROM THE DISPENSARIES I
BELIEVE THAT IS VERY LOW AYE AND
AS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
COLLECTED NINETY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION.
I STILL THINK THAT THAT'S VERY
LOW BECAUSE OF THE UP MICHAEL
BANKING ACCESS --
AS ALL OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW.
THERE IS A LOT OF CRIME
ASSOCIATED WITH --
COMPANIES INDIVIDUALS KEEPING
LARGE AMOUNTS OF CASH AT THEIR
HOME.
HOW BUSINESSES ARE IN THEIR
BACKYARDS AND FOR IBM WE
PURPOSES WE CANNOT AUDIT CASH?
A AND SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO OUR WORK.
A WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
WORK AROUND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT --
CREATED ANY --
BANKING ACCESS OR HAS --
OR HAS SHOWN THAT THEY'RE GONNA --
EASE BANKING ACCESS OF THE JUST
BE TOWED OR KILLED ANOTHER BILL
IN CONGRESS LAST WEEK.
AND SO THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT SB NINE THIRTY WOULD.
GIVE A STATE CHARTERED.
UP LICENSE OUGHT TO STATE
CHARTERED --
BANKS A SPECIAL CANNABIS LICENSE
WHERE THEY CAN --
EXCEPT CANNABIS ACCOUNTS FOR A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PURPOSES.
ONE TO PAY THEIR OUR STATE TAXES
ON NUMBER TWO TO PAY THEIR RENT
SWITCHES ARE USUALLY QUITE A LOT.
OF THREE TO PAY --
VENDORS --
THAT THEY DO BUSINESS WITH AND
THEN FOR TWO BY CALIFORNIA STATE
BONDS THIS WOULD BE A CLOSED
LOOP SYSTEM A IT WOULD BE WHAT
WITH PRIVATE INSURANCE AND HOME
WE BELIEVE YOU KNOW WE'D BE THE
FIRST STATEMENT NATION --
TO PASS THIS TYPE OF LAW.
AND WE BELIEVE IF THIS DOES PASS
OUT THIRTY AT LEAST THIRTY
STATES WILL BE CHINA PASSED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION I MEAN OUR
HOPE OBVIOUSLY IS TO HAVE
CONGRESS I'LL OPEN UP.
UP BANKING FOR THIS INDUSTRY
IT'S ANYWHERE BETWEEN EIGHT TO
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WITHOUT A BANKING AXIS IT IS
VERY VERY HARD TO DO BUSINESS IN
VERY HARD FOR US TO TRACK AT THE
TAX BOARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE NAME AN
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CARE ALSO BE UP THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S MORE US AND MORE WITH
CHAU YOUR ENTRY ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA STUDY IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA.
AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
WHERE MISTER CHAIR JASON RIGHT
UP AFTER CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU?
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AERONAUTICA BEHALF THE CANNABIS
JUST ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND COUNTY CRAFT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FUTURE MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF SEEM JEKYLL EVEN
BLACKBIRD LOGISTICS AND SUPPORT.
TIM MORNING DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR RIVER DISTRIBUTING A MY
COMPANY COLLECTED TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXCISE TAXES IN QUEUE.
TO ALL IN CASH DEATHLY IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER I'M A HALF OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING KATIE MADE ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANNABIS
DELIVERY THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
CAREERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA CANVAS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THINK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MALACHI ON MEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF WE'RE
ASKING THAT AS THE BILL GOES
FORD WE LOOK AT ACCESS TO
CAPITAL ISSUES.
FOR IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU.
I GOT A MOMENT BRIAN BARGER CEO
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CANDACE
COALITION EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA MINORITY LINES HIGH
EACH CHAPTER WE WITH LOVE FOR
THIS BILL ESPECIALLY AS HIS
PASSPORT. TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE
SAME ISSUES BUT ESPECIALLY
LOOKING AT MORE OF A PRACTICAL
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY WITH
PHYSICALLY BANKING GAS BEING
ABLE TO DO EMPLOYEE PAYROLL AS
WELL AS INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS FOR
LOWER BUSINESS.
ARE FOR LOWER INCOME BUSINESSES
BUT WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MAX REDLANDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALVARY CAMPUS DELIVERY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DID YOU MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING SPEAK.
COURT SEEN NONE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES WHAT IS NOT
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
NORMAL ELLEN CON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SAYING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CAN MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
WELL FIRST OFF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT THESE BUSINESSES
ARE FACING.
BUT I AM STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND --
HOW THIS?
MOVES US ALL THE WAY TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE SO IF I'M A LANDLORD.
AND I HAVE A CANNABIS INDUSTRY
BUSINESS THAT'S RUNNING MY
PROPERTY.
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE TO PAY ME
WITH THE BRIEFCASE FULL OF CASH
AND IF THIS BILL SHOULD PASS
THEM.
THEY PAYMENT WITH A CHECK DRAWN
ON A CATTLE CANNABIS CHARTER
BANK AND I DO WHAT WITH THAT
CHECK [inaudible]
WELL.
OKAY SERVICES SO THE THE VISION
IS THAT OUT WE WILL HAVE A
NETWORK OF BANKS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WOULD BE ABLE --
TO EXCEPT YOU CHECKED YOU WOULD
HAVE YOUR ACCOUNT --
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE SO.
YOU COULD TRANSACTIONS LIKE
EVERYONE THAT IT HAD TO BE ONE
OF THE BANKS IN THE NETWORK.
OKAY SO.
SEE YOU WOULDN'T BECAUSE IT YOU
ARE AS A LANDLORD I HAVE A BANK
ACCOUNT WITH A NON CAN'T OF THIS
CHARTER BANK.
AND I'VE GIVEN THE I'VE BEEN
GIVEN THIS CHECK DRAWN ON A
CANNABIS CHARTER BANK WOULD I DO
WITH THAT CHECK WILL YOU WOULD
OPEN UP AN ACCOUNT AT ONE OF THE
CANNABIS CHARTERED BANKS.
AND YOU WOULD HAVE TWO ACCOUNTS.
AT SO I DEPOSIT THE CHECK IN IN
MY ACCOUNT OF THE CANWEST HER
BACK AND YOU KNOW I GET MY MONEY
OUT OF THIS THING TAKEN UP BY
CASH IF YOU NEED IT.
OTHERWISE LEAVE IT IN THERE YOU
CAN USE IT TO YOU KNOW PAY YOUR
STATE TAXES --
YOUR FRANCHISE TAX BOARD EURO
YOUR SALES TAX IF YOU HAD ANY
SALES TAX YOU CAN BUY CALIFORNIA
BONDS WITH IT.
ON IF YOU WERE IN THE BUSINESS
AND YOU KNOW HAD OTHER FOLKS ARE
ALSO -- IN
THE BUSINESS YOU CAN ALSO USE
YOUR CANNABIS ACCOUNT YOUR
CHECKS -- TO
TO PAY OTHER VENDORS THAT ARE IN
THE BUSINESS MARKET BUT I CAN'T.
WRITE MYSELF A CHECK FROM THE
CANNABIS CHARTER BANK TO MY
REGULAR BUSINESS NOT RIGHT NOW
SO IF I IF I WANNA IF I DON'T
HAVE ANY USES THE USES THAT YOU
OUTLINED I HAVE TO GO.
GET THE SAME BRIEFCASE FULL OF
CASH FROM THE CHARTER BANK THAT
MY TENANT WOULD HAVE PAID ME.
YES AND AND YOU WOULDN'T PUT IT
INTO YOUR NON CANNABIS BANKS
THEY PUBLISH AT YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT DOWN.
AND THAT'S A REALITY AS SOON AS
YOU DEPOSIT MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CASH THAT
AND ASK YOU WHERE YOU GOT YOUR
MONEY FROM.
AND YOU SAY CANNABIS THAT WAS
SHUT DOWN ORDER COUNTERS
UNDERSTAND SO YOU EITHER HAVE TO
HIDE IT IN YOUR BACKYARD AT HOME
OR YOU KNOW --
SO I MEAN THIS IS A WAY TO CUT.
SAFEGUARD YOUR YOU KNOW.
YOUR HOUSE ARE AND MAKE SURE
THAT NOBODY CAN TAKE THE CASH.
OKAY SO OUT OF CURIOSITY WHY
INCLUDES THE PURCHASE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE BONDS IN THE
ALLOWED USES --
YES SO THAT WAS --
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S IDEA IS THAT --
WE WANT PEOPLE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THE MONEY SO YOU'RE NOT
SITTING EVERY MONTH TO GET FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN RENT YOU'RE
LIKE WHAT AM I GONNA DO WITH IT
I'M NOT EARNING ANY ANY INTEREST --
IT'S JUST SITTING THERE WHY
DON'T I DO SOMETHING WITH IT AND
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA STATE BONDS.
SO I THAT IS YOU KNOW REGULATED
BY CALIFORNIA WE BASICALLY HAVE --
TO BUILD A WALL AROUND
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THE MONEY AND
BECAUSE THE BONDS ARE.
NOT REGULATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON AND NOT BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
WHERE ALLOWING WOULD LIKE TO
ALLOW TAXPAYERS TO BE ABLE TO
BUY CALIFORNIA BONDS?
RIGHT I'M NOT EVEN GONNA FOLLOW
UP UNTIL THE WALL.
I'M NOT GOING THERE.
FINANCIAL WALL OR GOT ADVOCATE
NOT IN.
SO -- I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AYE
I'M WILL DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
COULDN'T GET CLOSER TO FULL
INTEGRATION WITH THE REGULAR
BANKING SYSTEM UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE DOING THE BEST THAT WE CAN --
BUT I IN THIS STILL ON IS THIS
SEEMS A VERY MUCH TO ME
[inaudible]
YES ABSOLUTELY ME PLEASE HELP US
ABOUT LOBBY CONGRESS AND AND THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS AND ON EVERY BILL
THAT GETS PRESENTED --
DIES ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY THANK YOU THAT.
WELCOME SPEAKING UP CONGRESS OR
OTHER FEDERAL PREEMPTION ISSUES
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THAT THIS WOULD BECOME LAW.
A I AM NOT ATTORNEY SO I REALLY
COULDN'T ANSWER THAT BUT WE FEEL
THAT -- AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
A DUTY TO PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS
AS WELL AS TRY TO YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE COMMERCE'S IS MOVING
FORWARD.
AND THAT'S WE BELIEVE OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD DEFEND US
IN IN ANY SORT OF ACTION OKAY.
THAT AS FAR AS THE THE NEED FOR
THIS I'M I'M IN FULL SWING WORK
WE WE YOU HEARD EARLIER WHEN THE
WITNESSES TALKED ABOUT IN ONE
QUARTER. TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
CASH FROM A DISTRIBUTOR IN MY IN
MY AREA HERE MY DISTRESS.
BROUGHT DOWN TO A STATE FACILITY
ALSO IN MY DISTRICT AND IF YOU
GO THERE YOU WOULD SEE.
CHP OFFICERS WITH.
A ARE FIFTEENS AND CRAZY ARSENAL
OF WEAPONRY MAKES IT LOOK SEEM
LIKE IT'S IN A WAR ZONE.
AND SO THEY'RE JUST PROTECTING
OF COURSE THE STATE BUILDING THE
STATE WORKERS WHICH IS A GOOD
THING BUT TRANSPORT IN BETWEEN
IN THE IN THE ORIGINAL --
PLACE GOING TO DESTINATION ALL
KINDS OF SECURITY ISSUE SO THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE SO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARTY ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM KITTY
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
HE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME --
MISS MAMA AND MISTER.
CAN TIME DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE%
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE IS THIS
YOUR FIRST TIME PRESENTING A
BILL.
AT YES IT IS MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WE WON'T COULD I HATE YOU THEN.
BARRY.
PRE SAY THAT IF FOR THE BENEFIT
OF SENATOR HERTZBERG.
PATH THAT IT JUST MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR MEMBERS SUCH ACCOMMODATIONS --
PUT YOU POSITION MEMBER OF MONTY
WHICH TO NOT YOU JUST AS LIKELY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THINKING YOU
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN IN ALL
SERIOUSNESS --
TO SENATOR HERTZBERG AND YOUR
OFFICE AND BOARDED LEGALIZATION
MEMBER OF MA --
ARE COMMITTEE STAFF HAS BEEN
WORKING DELUDE.
YOUR LEADERSHIP PARTICULARLY --
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION MEMBER MA
YOU SEE THIS OUT FIRST HAND A
WITH RESPECT TO TAXATION AND I
AM HOPEFUL THAT YOU'VE EVER DO
SO IN THE FUTURE IN YOUR OF YOUR
CAPACITIES AS WELL.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOW WILL
THAT TAKE UP THIS BILL AND WE
HAVE A QUORUM CREEK THEY NEVER
MUCH -- WE
NOW MOVE ON TO A QUICKLY TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THIS IS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT WHATSOEVER JONES SAWYER --
AND THIS IS SIMPLY A TECHNICAL.
BILL.
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY IT LIKE I I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THE TECHNICAL CLEAN
UP THE CLARIFIED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REMOVE.
THEIR POINT YOU FROM THE
CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS PANEL
LAST YEAR SENATE BILL NINETY
FOUR ADDED TO LEGISLATIVE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE APPEALS
PANEL IN ADDITION TO THE THREE
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
HOWEVER LANGUAGE IN S. B. NINETY
FOUR DID NOT INCLUDE.
SPICE IT AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMOVE THESE
APPOINTEES AS A RESULT PANEL
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SERVE ON THE
PANEL INDEFINITELY.
A BEAT FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WERE
CLARIFYING STATUTE APPOINTEES TO
CABS BOARD OF APPEALS.
PANEL SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF
THEIR PLANNING AUTHORITY MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IAGO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK APART SEEN NO DISTURBANCES
IN SUPPORT ANY.
THAT WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SEEN NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COULD MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY MERCHANTS OR JEWISH TO
CLOSE RESPECT FOR ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE
WILL HEAR THIS BILL WE HAD.
STEPS A QUORUM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS S. B..
THREE ELEVEN BY SENATOR PAN THIS
ALSO DOES ENJOY IN AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATIONS CENTERED PAN
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PATIENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR LOW I'M AND CAN BE MEMBERS.
MIGHT SET THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LAID OUT THE NOW SO
S. B. THREE ELEVEN WAS RECENTLY
AMENDED TO CLARIFY EXISTING LAW
TO ALLOW FOR PROOF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS GO FROM ONE TO STE
DISTRIBUTOR TO ANOTHER.
DUE TO A STRICT INTERPRETATION
CURRENT LAW THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL WILL NO LONGER
ALLOW FOR PROVED CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO GO FROM ONE
DISTRIBUTOR TO ANOTHER
DISTRIBUTOR.
AND THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
ACT WAS TO ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS
ARE TESTED BEFORE ENTERING THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET NOT PREVENT
TRANSFERRING OF TESTED PRODUCTS
BETWEEN LICENSE DISTRIBUTORS.
WE'RE ADDING URGENCY BECAUSE OF
THE ISSUE CAN BE ADDRESSED THIS
YEAR TO PREVENT UNNECESSARY
ENFORCEMENT BURDEN AND BACKLOG
ON THE BCC. TO BE CLEAR THIS
BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES AND
APPROVED CANNABIS PRODUCT TO
MOVE FROM ONE DISTRIBUTION
ANOTHER AND DOES NOT ADDRESS
TESTING STANDARDS BEING PLACED
ON CABS PRODUCTS.
ESPECIALLY ASK WHEN I VOTE AND I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND UP TO TWO MINUTES IN
TOTALITY.
IS PLEASED THAT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAUREN
FRAZIER AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION
SPONSORED S. B..
THREE ELEVEN CURRENT LAW READS
IT AFTER TESTING ALL CANNABIS
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS FIT FOR
AYE SALE MUST BE TRANSPORTED
ONLY FROM THE DISTRIBUTORS
PROMISES TO THE PROMISE ABOUT
LICENSE RETAILER MICRO BUSINESS.
SP THREE ELEVEN WOULD CLARIFY
THAT HAS A PRODUCT MAY ALSO
TRANSFER TO ANOTHER LICENSE
DISTRIBUTOR.
THIS CLARIFICATION IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE INTENT OF THE LAW WHICH
IS TO ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS MEET
TESTING REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
ENTERING THE RETAIL MARKET.
CONSIDER HUMBOLDT COUNTY
DISTRIBUTOR WHO AGGREGATES
PRODUCT PACKAGES IT AND TEST IT.
AND THEN TRANSFER THAT REACH
ALREADY PRODUCT TO ANOTHER
DISTRIBUTOR IN SAN FRANCISCO OR
LOS ANGELES.
IT'S NOT REASONABLE TO EXPECT
THE EVERY DISTRIBUTOR HAVE ITS
OWN DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES IN
EVERY MAJOR RETAIL MARKET.
BY ENFORCING THIS POLICY WE
WOULD BE PAVING THE PATH FOR
ONLY THE MOST WELL CAPITALIZE
DISTRIBUTORS TO OWN THE MARKET.
AND ARE VASTLY DISTRIBUTOR TO
DISTRIBUTOR PARTNERSHIPS ARE AN
ABSOLUTE NECESSITY.
LEVERAGING A STATEWIDE NETWORK
OF DISTRIBUTORS ENSURE SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN COMPETE WITH
LARGER PLAYERS WHO CAN AFFORD AN
INFRASTRUCTURE OF MULTIPLE
DISTRIBUTION HOUSE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST AND
MOST DIVERSE CAMPUS MARKET IN
THE WORLD OUR DISTRIBUTION
LANDSCAPE REQUIRE SPECIALIZATION
IN CRITICAL SUPPLY CHAIN
FUNCTIONS FROM STORAGE SERVICES
TO LAST NOW TRANSPORT TO
AGGREGATION AND QUALITY
VERIFICATION.
TODAY THE MAJORITY OF LICENSE
DISTRIBUTORS RELY AND DEPEND ON
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
DISTRIBUTORS.
WITHOUT THEM THERE WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT BOTTLENECKS IN THE
SUPPLY REACHING THE RETAIL
MARKET AND SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP
FOR LICENSE PRODUCERS DUE TO THE
IMPACT OF DUPLICATE TESTING
COSTS.
AND REDUNDANT QUARANTINE TIME ON
THE SAME PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED FOR RETAIL
SALE.
AS DISTRIBUTORS OUR JOB IS TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PRODUCT AS IT MOVES THROUGH THE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
THE ACT REQUIRES EVERY PRODUCT
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA TO BE IN A
TAMPER EVIDENT PACKAGE WITH A
UNIQUE IDENTIFIER.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF S. B.
THREE ELEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
DISTRIBUTORS TO DOCUMENT THE
CHAIN OF CUSTODY AND TO VERIFY
THE UNIQUE IDENTIFIER IN
CORRESPONDING CERTIFICATE OF
ANALYSIS FROM.
THE LICENSE TESTING OP.
IF EVERY TYPE ELEVEN
DISTRIBUTORS HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS OF COMPLIANCE THAT
EACH HAS ASSUMED THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENSURING
PRODUCTS ARE FIT FOR SALE BEFORE
ENTERING THE RETAIL MARKET.
OR OTHERWISE RISK LOSS OF
LICENSURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE TENTATIVE
LIST BUT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS AB PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR.
AND I THE OTHER SPONSOR SCCA IS
ALSO PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR I
THINK I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING
THE ABSENCE OF SUCH OPTIONS AS
THIS BILL PROVIDES ONLY
DISCOURAGES COMPLIANCE WITH IN
THE STATE'S COMPLEX.
ASSET OF CANNABIS LIES AND
LIMITS ACCESS TO SAFE QUALITY
PRODUCTS FOR PATIENTS SO WE DO
STRUGGLING KIRCHER SUPPORT TODAY
AND AGAIN ONE AT THINK THE
AUTHOR --
FOR FOR TAKING IF PLEASE MAKE IT
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
UP TO MY CAN NAME INFLATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CARE ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PALOMEQUE MAN I AM.
THAT WITH STRIVE SOCIETY AT
LARGE LICENSED CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR AND JURISDICTION OF
THE CITY OF NEVADA CITY.
AND ONE OF THOSE UPSTREAM
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTORS OF FOR
WHOM THIS WOULD BE A MAJOR
LIFELINE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
I AM CRISTINA QUINN I WORK FOR
POP AND BARKLEY AND S. B. THREE
ELEVEN IS CRUCIAL TO OUR
BUSINESS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MANDY
TINGLER AND THE DIRECTOR OF
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT FOR PAPA
AND BARCLAY WHICH IS A
DISTRIBUTION LICENSE HOLDER OUT
OF THE CITY OF THE EUREKA
CALIFORNIA --
I ALSO A PART OF A DISTRIBUTION
LICENSE COMPANY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO --
AND THAT IS CALLED PHOENIX
LOGISTIC PORT OF THREE ELEVEN
THINK YOU. TO MORE THAN A RIVER
DISTRIBUTING THE COMPLIANCE
STRUCTURE LIKE --
TO THINK THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR WORKING
THROUGH SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL --
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER IS THAT ANY TESTING
WHETHER WHICH PART OF THE
DISTRIBUTION SIDE WE DON WILL BE
IN FINAL PACKAGING --
THAT WAS OUR HUGE ISSUE THANKS
FOR ADDRESSING THAT WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MAX WAS ALONE SOME BATTLE FLOW
CON I CAMPUS --
PROCESSING DISTRIBUTION DELIVERY
COMPANY FOCAL AS A HUB UP IN
UKIAH WHERE THEY'RE ABLE TO GO
INTO.
TESTING OF FOUGHT IN THE FINAL
FORM --
ALONE INTO LARGER TESTING ATTACH
IT SOMETHING LARGER BATCH SIZES
IS MORE FISH AND LOWERS COSTS IN
THE SWISS PORTABLE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MY CLAIMS FROM
GUILD EXTRACTS WERE LIES TO
MANUFACTURING OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE ELEVEN OUR BUSINESS
DEPENDS ON MULTIPLE POINTS A
DISTRIBUTION TO SERVICE A
JURISDICTIONS WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE OUR OWN COVERAGE.
ADDITIONAL LAYERS A TESTAMENT
PLACER.
ECONOMIC A HARDSHIP ON US IN
ADDITION TO THE EXISTING HEAVY
ECONOMIC LOAD --
PLACED ON THE INDUSTRY CAN
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATORY
INTRICACIES WHILE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT.
A GOOD POLICY ISN'T REALLY BUILT
OVERNIGHT IT'S THREE LEVELS ONE
OF THEM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE JESSE
PRETTY PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF RISK
MANAGEMENT AND OF CANNABIS WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND IN
PROTECTING INDUSTRY RULE IRAN OF
MAKE SURE DOES NOT A BOTTLENECK
AND REALLY WANT TO HELP THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER SO THICK
YOU VERY MUCH A STRONG SUPPORT.
HEY GOOD MORNING CAN MEET ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANADA SLAVERY
IN THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
CAREERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THIS
IS CRUCIAL FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
TO THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA AND
BLACKBIRD LOGISTICS BOTH LICENSE
DISTRIBUTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SURCHARGES AND BRIGHT ON THE
AFTER CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE EXPERTS AS
WELL LIKE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MALACHI AMEND
CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE THINK
THIS WILL ALSO ULTIMATELY CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPACTED
POPULATIONS WHO ARE HAVING
STRUGGLES.
GETTING INTO THE INDUSTRY THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MONNING CUEVAS WITH THE CAN
TANAKA'S COMPANY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANVAS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR ALL
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THINK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MATT BROWN MBF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ELLEN COME FROM CALIFORNIA
NORMAL SPEAKING FOR CANNABIS
CONSUMERS OF CALIFORNIA WERE FOR
ANYTHING THAT LOWERS COSTS WHILE
ENSURING SAFETY AND THIS BILL
DOES BOTH WERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME UP TO THESE.
PODIUM.
AND UP TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER.
ALRIGHT MISS CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE --
MARKET PREY ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN
SYSTEMS WHICH OPERATES SAYS.
SEE FOUR DISTRO --
WE ARE A DISTRIBUTOR AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR DISTRO
WAS CO FOUNDED BY --
ERIC SPITZ THE FORMER I LOVE THE
FORMER OWNERS OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTER OF MY FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL LOCKYER.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE OUR LETTER --
YESTERDAY I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
LATENESS.
OF OUR OPPOSITION THEN OF
COMMUNICATED THAT TO THE AUTHOR.
OF THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE SP THREE THREE ONE ONE IS
THAT.
OF THIS MEASURE NOW MEN'S
EXISTING LAW TO ALLOW
DISTRIBUTORS TO TRANSPORT.
CANNABIS OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO
THEIR PROMISES OF ANOTHER.
BUT A CALIFORNIA'S POLICY WAS
SET UP TO SPECIFICALLY ENSURING
THAT TESTING OCCURS AT THE FINAL
POINT IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
PRIOR TO HEADING UP TO THE
RETAILER ITSELF I'LL POINT OUT
THAT -- THE
EXISTING LAW --
CURRENTLY PROVIDES FOR A TYPE
ELEVEN TRANSPORT ONLY
DISTRIBUTOR AND SO A IN OUR VIEW
THE CASE HAS NOT BEEN MADE.
SUPPORT ONLY DISTRIBUTION
LICENSE IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDING THE LAW OUR
CONCERN IS IS THAT WITH WITHOUT
THE STATE LAW CURRENTLY BEING
FULLY IMPLEMENTED I POINT TO
POINT OUT THAT TRACK AND TRACE.
HAS NOT YET COMMENCED THE JULY
ONE LABORATORY TESTING DEADLINE
IS JUST AROUND THE CORNER AND
THAT THIS IN IN FACT CREATES A
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MISCHIEF IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
BOTH FROM A FROM A TESTING
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO FROM THE
COLLECTION OF TAXES WITHOUT THIS
LAST MILE.
A TEST CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
CONSUMERS MAY BE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT IRREGULARITIES AND
CONFUSION THAT CURRENTLY INHIBIT --
INHABITS THE CALIFORNIA'S
NAISSANCE A ACCOUNT OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
STATE IN CALIFORNIA FROM OUR
STANDPOINT CANNOT TOLERATE THIS
RISK AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME SENATOR PANDEY WAS TO CLOSE.
THE THANK YOU I I WOULD JUST
MAKE NOTE THAT --
UNDER JUST BILL --
PRODUCTS WILL BE TESTED AND THEN
THEY WILL HAVE TO BE PACED IN A
TAMPER PROOF PACKAGE AS
ESTABLISHED BY LAW.
SO AT THAT POINT IN TIME --
BASICALLY THE PRODUCT IS IT
YOUNG HAS BEEN TESTED IT'S BEING
PLACED IN A IN AN AND A PRODUCT
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT WILL BE
NOTED THAT IF THERE IS ANY
EFFORT AT AT TRYING TO A TAMPER
IF THERE IS --
EFFORTS TO DO THAT I THINK THAT.
WE'RE NOT OTHERWISE HE'D HAVE TO
SAY WOULD HAVE TO TELL THE
RETEST EVERY SINGLE SAMPLE IF
YOU REALLY ARE TRYING TO CATCH.
OFTEN BETWEEN SO I THINK THAT
THIS BILL CERTAINLY ASSURES THAT
WE HAVE THOSE PROTECTIONS THOSE
A PATIENT PROTECTIONS THAT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN PLACE --
AND THIS WILL SIMPLY HELP
FACILITATE --
ACTUALLY TRANSPORT OF TESTED --
PRODUCT THAT'S ALREADY IN A TENT
IT INAPPROPRIATE PACKAGING
EXPECT WE ASK WHAT AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PENN
THIS DOES AND JOIN AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND WE WILL --
HERE TAKE UP THE BILL WHEN WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
OF THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN NOW GO
AGAIN IN FIVE ORDER WHICH IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B..
NINE THIRTY SEVEN WITH SENATOR
WIENER.
SENATOR WIENER WELCOME.
S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN ARE
INSURERS THAT --
MOTHERS WHO RETURNED TO WORK
AFTER GIVING BIRTH --
ARE ABLE --
TO AND WHO ARE LACTATING OR ABLE
TO EXPRESS OUR MILK AT WORK LOTS
OF THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO MAKE
A TERRIBLE CHOICE OF EITHER
RETURNING TO WORK AND US
STOPPING THEIR BREAST FEEDING.
WERE WANTING TO CONTINUE
BREASTFEEDING AND BEING UNABLE.
TO RETURN TO WORK THE BILL'S.
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT
ALLOWING A NEW MOTHERS TO THE
SIDE TO THEMSELVES --
WHEN THEY RETURN TO WORK --
I'M NOT MAKING THAT DECISION FOR
THEM WE WANT --
MOTHERS TO BE ABLE TO BREAST
THEIR CHILDREN AND WE WANT THEM
TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND THE TWO
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
OUR CURRENT LAW AYE IS VERY --
BAREBONES IT REQUIRES THAT AN
EMPLOYER ALLOW.
A WOMAN TO TAKE A BREAK TO
EXPRESS MY FORCEDTO DO IT
SITTING ON A TOILET.
AND THAT'S GREAT NOT TO FORCE
PEOPLE TO EXPRESS MARK WAS
SITTING ON A TOILET BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH.
SO THE BILL WILL PUT BASIC
STANDARDS IN PLACE REQUIRING ON
A PRIVATE AREA CAN BE --
A ROOM -- IF
I THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR EXAMPLE
IN A SMALLER --
COMMERCIAL SPACE I A CAN BE AYE
MORE TEMPORARY --
SET UP --
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF
MULTI UNIT --
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS ARE
DIFFERENT STORES OR OFFICES
SHARING.
OF ONE LACTATION SPACE --
THEIR SPACE ALSO OUT OF A TABLE
A CHAIR.
ON ACCESS TO POWER AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE REFRIGERATION AND
THOSE HAVE TO BE IN THE SPACE
BUT AT LEAST --
NEARBY.
SO IS BASIC IS FLEXIBLE --
THERE IS A HARDSHIP --
THAT CAN BE SOUGHT --
BY A AYE BUSINESS UP TO FIFTY
EMPLOYEES LOBBY WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND TAKEN QUITE A FEW
AMENDMENTS.
WHAT'S REALLY ADDRESSES MANY OF
THEIR CONCERNS AS WERE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THAT.
FOR A LARGER NEW --
A COMMERCIAL CONSTRUCTION AT
LEAST FIFTEEN THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET -- THAT
THERE BE --
LACTATION SPACE INCORPORATED IN
THE CONSTRUCTION THAT WOULD BE
SET.
RORY I JUST SAID I SHOULD SAY WE
ASK -- THE
NEXT SO THE CODE IS UPDATED.
THAT THAT TYPE OF PROVISION BE
INCLUDED.
LOTS OF THIS IS --
HARDCORE AND STEP. TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- NEW
MOTHERS ARE ABLE TO WORK.
AND BREAST FEED THEIR CHILD AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I WITH ME TODAY ARE BRIAN
HAWKING CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
AND W. HELPER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND UP TO TWO MINUTES IN
TOTALITY FOR ONCE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MONEY TO
BE HERE TODAY WERE PRAKASH
SPONSORS OF S. B..
NINE THIRTY SEVEN WAS ONE OF
THANK THE SENATOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AND HIS LEADERSHIP.
I'M SIMPLY PUT IT'S BEEN NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL LACTATING PARENTS ARE ABLE
TO MEET.
THE MOST BASIC NEED OF THEIR
CHILD.
WHICH IS PROVIDING FOOD --
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A BUNCH OF
STORIES AND WE KNOW ABOUT.
THE BENEFITS IN THE PROS OF
ACTUALLY BREAST FEEDING NAM.
ALSO I PROVIDING FOOD --
YOU KNOW THESE ARE FACTS THERE'S
BUT I DO WANT TO SHARE A
PERSONAL STORY --
MY WIFE USED TO WORK FOR A
UNIVERSITY ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS AGO.
I DID USED TO PROVIDE A
LACTATION ROOM HE WAS ALSO BEING
USED AS A STORAGE ROOM.
SHE FELT VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
USING THAT ROOM SO SHE WAS THE
ONE THAT WAS PUMPING --
DURING A LUNCH BREAK DURING
THEIR BREAKS INSIDE OUR CAR. ONE
DAY SHE COMES HOME SAYS HONEY WE
GOTTA CLEAN A MINIVAN.
OUTSIDE OF HOLLYWOOD HAD EVEN
THIRTY WE SHOULD HAVE YOU
DRIVING A MINIVAN.
OF YOU DON'T LOT LONG STORY
SHORT WE ENDED UP BUYING A
MINIVAN --
HAVE TO RELINQUISH MY SPORTS
COUPE IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
ATHLETES OF MY LIFE --
THEN HONOR AND THEN --
ON THE FINAL WEEKEND SHE SAYS
NOW WE WE GOTTA GET THIS --
MINIVAN TINTED SO WE GOT WE GOT
THE LOWER LIMIT TEND AND SHE
STILL FELT UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT
YOU KNOW A FEW SO BUT THE REASON
I'M SHARING THIS STORY WITH YOU
IS I'M --
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION'S MAY
CLAIM THAT THIS IS A JOB KILLER --
MY WIFE I YOU KNOW WE WITHOUT
AND WE WE BOTH AGREE THAT IT
WOULD BE BETTER FOR IT TO STAY
HOME.
WE FOUGHT UNCOMFORTABLE FOR HER
PUMPING WHEN IT WAS OVER A
HUNDRED DEGREES INSIDE A CAR --
SO WE ENDED UP.
YOU KNOW WE END UP BY MAKING A
DECISION WHERE SHE STAYED HOME
SO I'M YOU KNOW WE SAW ONE GOT
KILLED.
SO YOU KNOW IN THAT IN THAT
RESPECT --
THIS BILL IS MORE THAN ABOUT ME
THIS IS ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS THANK
YOU MOM I THINK IS ONLY AS WE
ARE AND WE ESCRIBIR GOT THAT TWO
MINUTES BUT YOU I SEE OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
[inaudible]
COURT [inaudible]
YEAH.
HIGH -- MY
NAME IS W. ALBERT CHAIR LOW AND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING COALITION IS
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AS BEING
ON THIRTY SEVEN I AM A NURSE IN
MY TEACHING CONSULTANT WITH UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER IN FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS.
I HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING BREAST
FEEDING MOTHERS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT RETURNING TO
WORK AND BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE
BREASTFEEDING.
THEY WORRY ABOUT HAVING A
PRIVATE SECURE PLACE TO PUMP.
THIS IS WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
IMPROVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS AND TO REQUIRE LIKE
TITIAN SPACE FOR SOME OF THE
BUILDINGS.
OF UC DAVIS HAS A GOLD PROGRAM
WHERE WE DO NOT ALLOW WOMEN TO
WALK MORE THAN FIVE MINUTES TO A
PUMP ROOM AND WE HAVE SEVENTY
AYE OF PUMP ROOMS ACROSS BOTH
CAMPUSES.
AND WE HAVE A BUILDING CODE
WHERE.
THE BUILDING WE HAVE THE ROOM --
DESIGNATED FOR LACTATION MELINDA
GATES RECENTLY SAID THAT THE
AMERICAN WORKFORCE --
HAS EVOLVED DRAMATICALLY OVER
THE COURSE OF MY LIFETIME BUT
THE AMERICAN WORKPLACE IS BARELY
CHANGED AT ALL.
IT'S TIME WE INSIST ON MAKING
WORK WORK BETTER FOR EVERYONE SB
NINE THIRTY SEVEN MOVES US IN
THAT DIRECTION TO TRANSFORM THE
WORKPLACE CULTURE THAT
NORMALIZES LACTATION SUPPORT.
AS AN ACCEPTED PART OF WORK LIFE
BALANCE TRANSFORMATION IN THE
WORKPLACE THAT SUPPORTS
LACTATING PARENTS IS A NECESSITY
AS MOTHERS OUR FASTEST GROWING
SEGMENT.
OF THE U. S. WORKFORCE 75% ARE
EMPLOYED FULL TIME MANY ARE SO
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR FAMILY DATES
YOU MOST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
DO WE AT NOW --
WOULD LIKE HELP UP POTS FOR ONE
MOMENT JUST TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM COMEDIC SHAPE THE WHOLE
ROLE.
LOW HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
GREAT RIVER STEPS DECORUM NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE JUST
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING CARE ROTH ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND THE CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE CARUANA ON BEHALF OF
FIRST HAVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
TRACE MACHADO WITH COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SPENCER MERTON COLLEGE
OBGYN STITCH NINE IN SUPPORT.
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
RYAN BOGS DIRECTOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR I AM A FIVE ONE C.
THREE LOCAL NONPROFIT WE SERVICE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY OUR BOARD. 75%
MINORITY WOMEN SO WE ARE VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF MAKING SURE WHATEVER
COULD BE BOBBY DOT FOR
ESPECIALLY BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
ARE WOMEN ALSO EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
WOMEN.
THAT THEY ARE FAIRLY ASSESSING
NOT DISCRIMINATE.
SO THANK YOU SIR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
[inaudible]
TO PORTS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND MY APOLOGIES WE
AT SOME.
WE HAD ONE MEMBER SLIP OUT SO WE
STILL NEED ONE MORE ADDITIONAL
MEMBER -- TO
STEPS A QUORUM.
SOBRE STILL ACTING AS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND SO SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NOW LIKE TO CALL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE PODIUM.
AND BECAUSE WE'VE ALLOWED
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO SPEAK UP
TO THREE MINUTES WILL ALLOW THE
SAME COMPETITIONS HE WAS WELL SO
HOWEVERYOU WISH TO DO SO IN
TOTALITY THREE MINUTES.
PLEASE GO FOOD PRESENT WHENEVER
READY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S LAURA
CURTIS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND JUST A COUPLE THINGS TO
START OFF AND THIS IS NOT A
DESIGNATED JOB KILLER CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS THE POLICY BEHIND THE
BILL.
A WE WANNA WELCOME OUR AYE
FEMALE EMPLOYEES BACK TO WORK AS
WELL AS THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
DOES.
THE SAME AND WANTS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE COMFORTABLE IN
THEIR BREAST FEEDING ABILITIES
HOWEVER THAT WE DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL.
THE BILL WAYS AND TO BE
STRUCTURED AFTER THE SAN
FRANCISCO ORDINANCE HOWEVER
THERE ARE TWO LARGE PROVISIONS A
IN THE BILL PART OF IT'S A
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE ARCHIVAL
DISCUSSED.
BUT THE OTHER ISSUE IS THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
CURRENTLY THE SAN FRANCISCO
ORDINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION NEED
FORSMAN MEASURES THROUGH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS WOULD ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE TO
BRING A EVEN IF THEY'RE PROVIDE
THE ACTUAL ELECTED ACCOMMODATION
THEY COULD STILL BRING THE RIGHT
OF ACTION FOR THE SMALLER
NUANCES OF THE BILL SUCH AS
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND SO THAT'S A HUGE CHANGE IN
THE LAW FOR US --
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS MUCH MORE
EXPANSIVE AT THE CURRENT
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION IS
SIMPLY A PLACE OTHER THAN A
BATHROOM STALL SU GOING FROM A
ONE TO TWO SENTENCE REGULATION.
TO A MULTI PAGE REGULATION AND
EMPLOYERS AND JUST TRYING TO
COME TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY I'M A COMPLY WITH THIS
ORDINANCE WITHOUT THE THREAT OF
CONTINUED LITIGATION OVERSIGHT
ON MY NEW ISSUES.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY WE
WE ARE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR AND WE APPRECIATE
HIS OFFICE ABILITY TO WORK WITH
US BUT WE DO FEEL WERE AT A
POSITION RIGHT NOW WITH THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND THE
BUILDING CODE ORDINANCES AS WELL.
SOME OTHER ISSUES WITH THE BILL
THAT WE'RE NOT SURE AND HOW
MOVEMENT ALBUM AND THAT'S WHEN
THE FORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
HARD OF THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
TRIED TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORS
OF THE BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
GET TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
ORDINANCE.
WHICH WAS JUST PASSED LAST YEAR
AND HAS JUST STARTED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
THE ISSUE FOR OUR MEMBERS IS
THAT IT DIRECTS.
PHYSICAL BUILDING OF ROOM
SPECIFIED FOR A CERTAIN ACTIVITY
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE REALLY IN
THE BUILDING CODE THAT IS
SIMILAR TO THIS.
SO FOR A LOT OF YOUR BILL DOUBTS
ON EXISTING BUILDINGS WHICH ARE
MEMBERS ARE CURRENTLY DOING
WE'VE ACTUALLY PROVIDED
INFORMATION.
ON SOME OF THESE BILL DOUBTS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ANYWHERE FROM
A THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR TWO
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
EXPENSE COURSE THE UPPER END OF
THAT IS A VERY VERY NICE
APPORTIONED ROOM.
BUT THIS BILL IS STILL TAKING A
AND APPROACH TO THIS WHERE
YOU'RE REQUIRING.
PACIFIC BELL ROOMS AND TENANT
IMPROVEMENTS ULTIMATELY MY
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO DO THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE FINE WITH THAT
BUT THAT COSTS.
WILL ALL GET PASSED ALONG TO THE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
WE'RE HOPING THAT WE HAVE AN
APPROACH THAT IS MUCH SO MORE
SIMILAR TO CURRENT LAW AND WE'RE
WORKING ON IN THIS BUILDING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN WHERE EMPLOYERS
CAN FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO PROVIDE THIS
ACCOMMODATION WITHOUT ACTUALLY
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY CONSTRUCT A
ROOM?
SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PAYMENT
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
I MISTER CHAIR CHRIS MCCAIN THE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION ALSO ON
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS
WHY WERE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DAY BUTLER ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK A COALITION OF LOCAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ORGANIZATIONS.
HEARING THE SACRAMENTO
MARKETPLACE ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATIE HANSEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED ON THIS BILL.
KITTEN COLEMAN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION I WERE OPPOSED TO
THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM CAN YOU MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'M SO SORRY THAT YOUR WITNESS
LOST A SPORTS CAR.
TRY TRY BREASTFEEDING.
OR DOING THIS I WOULD SUGGEST IT
BUT AND I'M YOUR GUIDE BRACE THE
MANY VIA NOTES A WONDERFUL
VEHICLE --
IT'S IT'S FANTASTIC --
I IN SERIOUSNESS KNOW RICK I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS TO MAKE --
THIS.
I EASIER FOR WOMEN RETURNING TO
THE WORKPLACE THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN BE DOING TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR WOMEN TO RETURN TO THE
WORKPLACE --
AND I I'VE BEEN PLEASED TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS --
JUST THIS YEAR TO TRYING TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR EMPLOYERS HAVE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS --
I ISSUE.
THOUGH THE OPPOSITION IS
EXPRESSED AS PAGA.
AND PAM IF WE ARE TOO
RESTRICTIVE WITH VAGUE TERMS WE
DO OPEN OUR EMPLOYERS OUT WHO
ARE TRYING TO TAKE GOOD CARE OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES --
TO NOT ONLY LAWSUITS BUT VERY
COSTLY LAWSUITS THAT MAY MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO HAVE
MORE WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE.
AND SO I'M IT THERE AND I WANNA.
BE GRATEFUL TO HER FOR ME ON WHY
IT'S NECESSARY TO EXPAND THE
APPLICATION OF PAGA IN THIS AREA.
IF WE DON'T HAVE VERY VERY
PRECISE TERMS AND HAVE ANOTHER
FOLLOW UP QUESTION AFTER THAT.
SURE -- SO --
BONGOS OF COURSE.
APPLIES TO A LOT OF A NUMBER OF
VERSIONS OF THE LABOR CODE IT'S
NOT WE'RE NOT CREATING A NEW
THING HERE.
BUT YOU KNOW I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT --
TO HOW THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND PARTICULARLY BY YEAH
THOUGH THE BILL DOES ALLOW THE
OPTION OF COMPLETE FIRE
COMPLAINT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER --
NO DISRESPECT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THAT'S NOT A FAST
PROCESS AND IF YOU ARE A WOMAN
RETURNED WORKING A LOT TING.
THERE'S A TIME HORIZON ON IT IT
TAKES A FEW YEARS TO RESOLVE SO
BE IT.
DOESN'T RESOLVE IN A YOU KNOW A
FEW MONTHS SIR.
YEAR OR SO --
IT BECOMES MOOTED OUT AND SO --
IF WE DON'T HAVE EFFECTIVE AND
MORE EXPEDITIOUS ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS LIGHT.
EVEN THE THREAT OF A LAWSUIT IN
TERMS OF GETTING EMPLOYERS TO
COMPLY -- I
THINK THIS WILL BECOME VERY VERY
HARD TO ENFORCE NOT IMPOSSIBLE
VERY HARD --
AND SO THAT THAT'S WHY WE CHOSE.
OUGHT TO PUT IN THERE THIS IS A
TIME SENSITIVE THING IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER UNFORTUNATELY
IS NOT.
A FAST ENOUGH ROUTE TO
ENFORCEMENT.
AND I THINK APPRECIATE THAT ANNA
AND CERTAINLY AGAIN YOU'RE
YOU'RE CORRECT BUT THE TIME
HORIZON THERE'S NOTHING THAT
WOULD KEEP US FROM SAYING THAT
THIS HAS TO BE EXPEDITED IN
RESOLVED WITHIN.
A TWO WEEK THIRTY DAY PERIOD I'M
AND AND PUTTING THAT ON THERE I
REALIZED I AYE WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER CAMILO QUICKLY THE
GRATEFUL THAT APPROPRIATIONS --
IN SERIOUSNESS ALSO YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE HAD AND I'VE WORKED
WITH WOMEN HIS RETURN TO THE
WORKPLACE AT WHILE LACTATING
AFTER THEIR CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
BORN AND THEY PREFER MANY THAT
I'VE WORKED WITH OVER THERE IT'S
EMPLOYEES OR COLLEAGUES AT A LAW
FIRM BUT PREFERRED TO HAVE THEIR
OWN.
SPACE TO BE ABLE TO USE THEIR
OFFICE.
I THEY THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANOTHER SPACE THEY'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH --
BUT IS SPACES OUR OWN PRIVATE
SPACE THEIR OWN OFFICE IN MY
READ OF THIS BILL.
MAKES EMPLOYER POTENTIALLY
SUBJECT TO A POSSIBLE LAWSUIT.
IF AN EMPLOYEE CHOOSES. TO USE
THEIR OFFICE AND THEY DON'T GO
AHEAD AND BUILD THAT SEPARATE
SPACE THAT MAY NOT BE.
WHAT EMPLOYEES WANT BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
FOR REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
WHAT THE HELL OTHER THE REALITY
IS IS A LARGE IT?
KNOWS WHO DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN.
OFFICES OUTSIDE EVEN AND WORK AS
A LAWYER I HAD MY OWN OFFICE.
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF STAFF TO
WE DIDN'T AND SO AND THE TREND
OF COURSE IS NOT AS MOVING MORE
MORE AWAY.
OFTEN PRIVATE OFFICES SO YES A
WOMAN OF COURSE IS THE OPTION OF
OF EXPRESSING MILK IN HER OWN
OFFICE AND THAT'S HER.
CHOICE BUT MOST WOMEN DON'T HAVE
A PRIVATE OFFICE BUT I AM
REALIZE THAT I AM HAVING HAD
EMPLOYEES ALSO IN THAT SITUATION
BUT I THE POINT I'M MAKING IS IF
THERE IS SPACE THAT WORKS.
UNDER IT AND IS A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION FOR BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE IN A
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY I WOULD LIKE
IS EMPLOYERS TO SUCCEED AND NOT
HAVE A DISINCENTIVE TO HIRE
WOMEN.
NOT HAVE A DISINCENTIVE TO HELP
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BRING MORE
WOMEN WHO WANT TO COME INTO THE
WORKPLACE AFTER HAVING CHILDREN
WE PUT SO MANY BARRIERS UP
BEFORE THEM.
THAT -- NO
BEING FRANKLY RIGID ABOUT WHAT
WORK SPACE THEY USE AND HAVE TO
BUILD INSTEAD OF ALLOWING THEM
TO WORK IT OUT IS --
IS IS AN IMPEDIMENT MY SECOND
QUESTION MATES MY THIRD IS DOES
THIS APPLY EQUALLY TO STATE
EMPLOYERS SO THE SUPPLIES 1100%.
UP WE HAVE THE SAME PENALTIES
SAN AND OTHERWISE SO WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL STATE OFFICES ALSO.
A A COMEDY AND BUILD NEW SPACE
TO DO THIS --
YES AND AND ALSO SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
CHINA --
COURSE WE PASSED LEGISLATION IN
THE PAST THAT WAS TO HELP
STUDENTS AND STAFF WHO WERE --
LACTATING TO HAVE A PLACE THAT
IS A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION --
FOR EXPRESS MILK I I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS AND I THINK THE PAGA
CONCERNS ARE VALID AND
ESPECIALLY FOR GONNA HAVE PAGA.
THAT THE TERMINOLOGY JUST HAS TO
BE PRECISE --
SO THAT WE ARE NOT ULTIMATELY
EXTRACTING RESOURCES FROM THE
VERY EMPLOYERS WHO ARE TRYING TO
SUPPORT WOMEN RETURNING TO THE
WORKPLACE --
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
I'M WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
MINI VAN MY MY REMARKS WOULD BE
SOMEWHAT ONLINE WITH A MS
BAKER'S --
AND I'M SORRY I MISSED THE
PEARLY APART THE PRESENTATION
BUT IT IS THIS INTENDED TO BE
CONJOINED WITH THE THE MOANS
<c.green> BE NINETEEN EIGHT NINETEEN</c>
SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS OVER.
ON THE SENATE SIDE WHICH IS AS I
UNDERSTAND IS NOT HOW THE PAGA.
WHICH IT IS CORRECT THEIR FOOD
THE BILLS ARE NOT THEY'RE NOT
JOINS THEY ARE.
COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH OTHER THAN
I AM ANYWAY.
AND CONFLICTS --
I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
LIMON SPILL --
DIED.
HOW IT IS IT'S NARROWER THAN
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE --
IT'S AYE SUPPORTER BILL --
TO GOOD BILL BUT THIS IS A IT'S
A BROADER BILL IN TERMS OF LIKE
ASIAN ACCESS IN THE WORKPLACE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
SENATOR WITH A WITH RESPECT TO
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS
YOUR ABILITY TO CURE THAT AS
PART OF THAT --
THEIR ABILITY TO CURE I THINK
[inaudible]
AND AND THE LITTLE LIKE I THINK
I DON'T KNOW WE HAVE TO AT NIGHT
OR OF I DON'T KNOW I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE THAT --
IN THEIR BY WILL SAY.
WE HAVE BEEN --
DESPITE THE UC SYSTEM YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING INTENSIVELY
AND I MEAN INTENSIVELY WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SINCE THE DAY
WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL I A
PERSON THAT WOULD THEM.
BY STAFF HAS SPENT HOURS AND
HOURS GOING OVER WE TALK ABOUT
THE TOPIC TIGHTENING THE
LANGUAGE WE'VE GONE THROUGH
MYSELF ON THE LINE BY LINE. FOR
THE BILL WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY LINES IS A I DON'T
CONSIDER YOUR BILL A JOB KILLER
BILL AND ALTHOUGH --
NO DISTINCTION SOUNDS RATHER
ARBITRARY TO ME I'M NOT SURE
WHERE JOB KILLER STARTS SOON AND
AND STOPS ANYMORE --
BUT MY QUESTION IS VERY SPECIFIC
AND THAT'S JUST WHETHER THERE'S
A RIGHT TO CARE THAT IS.
A INCORPORATED INTO THE
ENFORCEMENT SCHEME BECAUSE IF
THERE'S NOT --
ON ON AN ISSUE LIKE THIS WHERE
SOMEBODY MIGHT FAILED UP A SIGN
OR A YOU KNOW.
SOMETHING BECAUSE OF OF THAT
NATURE AND GETS TAGGED WITH A
LAWSUIT --
DOT THAT'S PROBLEMATIC WE WE I
THOUGHT IN THERE NOW THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'RE HAPPY
TAKE A LOOK AT AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES KINDS OF ISSUES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS GOOD
ENFORCEMENT --
WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN AND TAKING
A LOOK AT THAT THANK YOU WILL BE
LOOKING FOR THAT ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU RICHARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME SENATOR
WIENER DO WISH TO CLOSE.
YES I THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR THE AYE QUESTIONS
THAT I AND AS I MENTIONED WE ARE --
I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO MAKING
SURE THESE KINDS OF BILLS CAN BE
ADMINISTERED IN THE WORKPLACE
NOT WHAT WE HAVE.
I TRIED TO BE VERY COLLABORATIVE
I WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AYE BUT WE JUST NEED TO BE VERY
CLEAR THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE THERE SO
MANY BARRIERS WOMEN RETURNING TO
WORK AFTER THEY GIVE BIRTH.
AND YOU KNOW THAT I KNOW THAT WE
ALL KNOW THAT --
AND WE CAN COUNT THE WAYS ALL
THE BARRIERS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
I AM YOU KNOW THAT THE THE
SPORTS CAR THING NOT
WITHSTANDING.
BRING THEIR PACK THAT A WOMAN
FELT THE NEED [inaudible] TO
PURCHASE A MINIVAN WITH TINTED
WINDOWS BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
WHERE IN HER WORKPLACE THAT SHE
FELT COMFORTABLE EXPRESSING MILK
[inaudible]
SO SHE'S WENT AND GOT A MINI VAN
WITH TINTED WINDOWS AND THAT HE
WAS EXPRESSING OUT THERE NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO DO THAT.
EVER [inaudible]
EVER.
AND IT IS YOU KNOW AND WHEN
COURSE SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE
SPACES.
I WISH SIX OF THE DATA SOME OF
THEM DO WE HAVE SOME FANTASTIC
EMPLOYERS TO BEND OVER BACKWARDS.
BUT MANY DON'T.
I AND PARTICULARLY FOR LOWER
WAGES [inaudible]
FEMALE WORKERS --
FOR WORKERS WHO ARE IN THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY WORKERS WHO DO
NOT HAVE.
AN OFFICE OR A DESK --
WHO ARE IN THE KIND A WORKPLACE
WHERE THERE'S REALLY NOWHERE?
FOR THEM TO GO.
ON ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS IS
NOT SOME HEAVY BURDEN.
IT'S A PRIVATE SPACE FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO EXPRESS MILK WITH A
TABLE A CHAIR AN ELECTRIC OUTLET.
AND A REFRIGERATOR SOMEWHERE
NEARBY.
THAT IS NOT AN EX DOT WHITES NOT
A JOB KILLER IT'S NOT IT SOME
SORT OF CRAZY EXTREME.
OUR REQUIREMENT JUST A PRIVATE
SPACE WITH THE TABLE CHAIR AN
ELECTRICAL OUTLET I'VE IT'S NOT
ASKING A LOT RESPECT WEBSPHERE
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
WIENER --
THIS -- DOES
ENJOYING AYE RECOMMENDATION I
WILL ALSO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH RESPECT TO THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES CERTAINLY IN YOUR
CLOSING --
AS YOU HIGHLIGHTED THAT EXAMPLE.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE CONVERSATION WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
WILLINGNESS.
TO A CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
TO ADDRESS ANY OF THE
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS.
AND AGAIN WE WILL TAKE UP OF
THIS BILL MAY HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE OKAY NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN WHICH IS S. B. NINE NINE
NINE BY SENATOR MORRELL.
SEN MORALE WELCOME PLEASE FEEL
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WHO'S ON HEALTH VERY ARE THERE
HEY I GOTTA OF FAVOR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE THAT TO BILLS PRESENT.
ONE TRULY AS A SIMPLE BILL.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN IF IF WE CAN
HIT THAT ONE FIRST THAT SURELY
OUT HERE IN TEN MINUTES AND
ABSOLUTELY THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTEEN THIS DOES IN JOIN AYE
AYE.
OKAY AND MANY OTHER ONE MAY TAKE
A LITTLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK YOU --
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE OUT.
LINING AND GOOD WORK THEY'VE
DONE IN ME AND THEN THE
AMENDMENT SO THEY ARE CLARIFYING
THE NATURE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM
THE PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR ACT
CURRENTLY REQUIRES.
A LICENSEE OR QUALIFIED MANAGER
WHO POSSESSES A VALID FIRE ARMS
QUALIFICATION. TO COMPLYING WITH
TO COMPLY WITH THE SUBJECT. TO
CERTAIN PROVISIONS INSCRIBED IN
THE PRIVATE SECURITY SERVICE
SAYS ACT RELATED --
TO THESE PERMITS AS A RESULT
LICENSES HAVE TO REFERENCE TO
SEPARATE CODE SECTIONS IN ORDER
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW THUS CAUSING AND
NECESSARY CONFUSION SP.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN WILL FIX THIS
BY SIMPLY AND MANY IN THE
PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS ACT.
SO THAT THE FIREARM SECTIONS THE
ACT REFERENCES.
ARM IN THE SECURITY SERVICES
AFTER INSTEAD INCLUDED DIRECTLY
IN THAT ACT PLACEMENT OF THESE
PROVISIONS IN THE PER UP.
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR ACT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE THESE PRESENT
PROVISIONS ARE CLEAR TO THE
LICENSEES WITHOUT HAVING TO LOOK.
TO OTHER PROVISIONS OF LAW THAT
APPLY TO PROPRIETARY SECURITY
SERVICES WITH ME TODAY ARE LUKE
PATTERSON AND JERRY DESMOND
REPRESENTING THEIR THE SPONSOR
THE BILL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS.
AND SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF UP TO TWO
MINUTES IN TOTALITY HUMANITY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M LOOK PATTERSON.
OF A CALIFORNIA LICENSE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR FOUNDER OF CAPITAL
LEGAL INVESTIGATIONS.
AND WE URGE AYE VOTE ON THIS
MATTER IT WILL CLARIFY THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
SECURITY OFFICERS AND PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS TO MAKE IT MUCH
MORE SIMPLE FOR PEOPLE NOT TO
GET CONFUSED THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS JERRY DOES MIDDLE
BEHALF OF CALLIE JUST ONE
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
WORK OF THE ARE OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TO MAKE SURE AS WE MOVE
THE PROVISIONS OVER THAT WE HAVE.
A DOCTOR A SPECIFIC AND ACCURATE
IN THE P. I ACT AND WE SUPPORT
THE* GENNIFER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WOODS IS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES ARE
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CAN YOU MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
AND SENATOR MARK DO WHICH FOR A
RESPECTFUL AYE VOTE PLEASE
GRADING YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL
GET WILL TAKE UP THAT ITEM WHEN
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THEN WE'LL HEAD BACK TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS S.
BEING. NINE NINE NINE NINE NINE
NINE A VERY SIMPLE BILL
[inaudible]
SELF -- GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
NINE NINE NINE WILL REPEAL SOME
VERY LIMITED --
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS FOR
BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGIST.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY CALL AUTHORS FOR
THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S OCCUPATIONAL SYSTEM
OF LICENSEE IS INHIBITING THE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY OF LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME ENTREPRENEURS WHO
ARE FOLK FORCE. TO FOCUS ARE OF
VERY EXPENSIVE AND UNNECESSARY
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING TO
PROCESS IN ORDER TO MAKE A
LIVING -- AS
WE'VE RESEARCHED THIS.
SOME OF THESE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
WHICH I'M FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS BUT
CHARGE TUITION UP TO TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST.
FOR SOME OF THE THINGS LIKE
SHAMPOOING HAIR FOR A LICENSE
WHICH SEEMS TO BE VERY TOUGH
ESPECIALLY.
BECAUSE THERE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND MOST OF IT TAKES STUDENT
LOANS WITH --
YOU KNOW I'M SURE THEY GET JOBS
WITH THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT A
RECENT STUDY BY THE ARTS PRETTY.
IT SHOULD INSTITUTE FOUND.
THERE ARE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
IS LINKED WITH AS MUCH UP TO A
FIFTEEN POINT 4% INCREASE --
IN -- INCOME
INEQUALITY.
IN NINETEEN OR TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN UNDER THE OBAMA
PRESIDENCY THE WHITE HOUSE FOUND
NEGATIVE OF FACTS OF LICENSING.
THAT THE BALK OF THEIR IMPERIAL
DATA AND EVIDENCE SHOW THAT
LICENSING DOES NOT PROMOTE A
BETTER QUALITY OR SAFETY
STANDARDS.
AGAIN UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
ADMINISTRATION TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SAID IT SERVES AS A
BARRIER. TO ENTRY FOR MINORITY
AND LOW INCOME WORKERS TO ENTER
THE JOB MARKET.
THERE IS NO BETTER EXAMPLE OF
THIS THEN IN CALIFORNIA'S WE SEE
IN THE IN THIS LEASE FEELS IN
ORDER TO PROFESSIONALLY ARRANGED
DRESS AND WAY OR SHAMPOO HERE AS
AN EXAMPLE.
GET THIS CALIFORNIA LICENSING
REQUIRES INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED HOURS
[inaudible]
OF TRAINING.
PAST TWO EXAMS ONE EXAMS A
WRITTEN EXAM.
ANOTHER ONE THEY CALL A
PRACTICAL EXAMINATION THEN PAY
UP TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND FEES.
BUT GET THIS IS WE RESEARCH
THESE DIFFERENT WEBSITES.
THE TUITION STAY SHAMPOO HAIR
RANGES ANYWHERE FROM. SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TUITION.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY FOR THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE I THINK FOLKS --
MOM SP NINE NINE NINE FOCUSES
ONLY ON THESE PRACTICES AND DOES
NOT TARGET.
THE ENTIRE SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
AND CALL US MY TOP POLITICS AS
THE OPPOSITION HAS.
ARM HAS MISREPRESENTED IT --
THIS BILL DOES NOT GO AFTER
BARBERS ARE THEY ARE --
INDUSTRY OR ANY OTHER INDUSTRY
FOR THAT.
BOMB.
MATTER BUT RATHER ATTEMPTS TO
HELP THOSE TRAIN INTO THE
INDUSTRY AGAIN THIS SYSTEM IS
ABOUT ACCESS TO WORK THAT'S ALL
IT IS THIS BILL.
IS WERE TRYING TO MAKE IT SO
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO WORK.
BECAUSE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
LIVE EXPRESSES TOO EXPENSIVE.
THESE OCCUPATIONS ARE ON LICENSE
WITH NO REPORTEDLY DETRIMENTAL
AFFECTS IN OTHER STATES THESE
LICENSE REQUIREMENTS ARE
GOVERNMENT SPONSOR BARRIER TO
COMPETITION.
THE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HAS
CITED THE FACT THAT NEXT YEAR
THE BOARD --
THEIR BOARD IS UP FOR SUNSET
REVIEW AND THIS ISSUE CAN BE
ADDRESSED THEM HOWEVER I
DISAGREE THAT IT SEEMS LIKE.
ONCE SOMETHING HAS PUT IN THE
LAW IT VERY RARELY IS RESCINDED
SO THERE'S NO REASON.
THAT THIS COMPLETELY SAFE PRO
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION ON
LICENSING WE SHOULD MAKE THESE
CHANGES NOW IN FREE UP THESE
PRACTICES. FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO WORK THE OPPOSITION IS
ALSO CLAIM THAT IF WE DE
REGULATE WE WILL SEE AN INCREASE
AN UNLICENSED BEHAVIOR.
AND PEOPLE SAYING THEY ARE ONLY
PRACTICING SHAMPOO WHEN IN
REALITY.
THEY'RE DOING A MULTITUDE OF
MANY OTHER THINGS [inaudible]
HOWEVER --
THESE INDIVIDUALS STILL.
WILL BE WORKING IN LICENSE
ALIGNS.
WITH OWNERS WHO HAVE LICENSE WHO
OVERSEE THEIR WORK AND THERE ARE
OF COURSE WILL BE RESPONSIVE
ONCE.
A OPPONENTS ALSO CLAIM THAT THE
CURRENT.
LICENSE REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE
TRAINING ON SPOTTING SCALP
DISEASES AND THEY ARGUE THAT THE
LICENSING WILL LEAD TO POTENTIAL
OVERSIGHTS IN THIS AREA.
BUT ONE THING I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR BY NO MEANS --
IN THIS TRAINING DO THEY RECEIVE
ANY KIND OF IN DEPTH MEDICAL
TRAINING --
IN THEIR COURSES TO IDENTIFYTHAT NOT ALSO IF I WAS AN OWNER
OF A SALON --
I CERTAINLY WOULD NOT MAKE IT
ADVISABLE TO HAVE MY STAFF
ATTEMPTING TO IDENTIFY.
AND POINT OUT DISEASES BECAUSE
OF COULD POSE A SERIOUS
LIABILITY.
ON THE PART OF THE OWNER IN AND
ALSO REMEMBER --
THERE ASK IN THE SHAMPOO WORST.
TO HAVE THIS EDUCATION.
BUT THE LICENSE BEAUTICIANS AND
BARBERS ALREADY HAVE THIS
LICENSE SO IF THEY WANT.
TO POINT OUT THEY CAN'T AND BY
THE WAY ON ON THIS THING ON
SHAMPOOING.
VERSES.
BARBERINI.
WE MY STAFF TOOK --
FORTY HAIR SALONS IN EVERYBODY'S
DISTRICT AND IT WAS RARE TO FIND
ANY COMPLAINTS ON YELP.
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ON SHAMPOOING
BUT WE FOUND A LOT.
ON PEOPLE WHO CUT HAIR AND YOU
KNOW THE PETITIONS --
AND THOSE WERE LICENSE PEOPLE
BUT SO FAR SHAMPOOING THEY WERE
VERY CLEAN --
DAMAGE OVERWHELMING HUNDREDS OF
COMPLAINTS AND WILL NOT OLLIER
AREAS BUT AS WE TOTAL A MOP AND
IT WAS WITH PEOPLE WHO HAD
LICENSE SO AGAIN I THINK IT'S
UNFAIR. TO TALK ABOUT --
THAT THERE'S GREAT PROBLEMS HERE
WAS SHAMPOOING HERE.
OR CURRENTLY IN HERE.
HE ARE NOT THANK --
SO WE SHOULD NOT EXPECT OR
SHAMPOO IS TO SERVE AS A ROLL OF
DOCTORS IN OUR SOCIETY WHICH WAS
KINDA POINTED OUT TO ME BY.
BY THE THEIR ASSOCIATION BUT ANY
WE AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE THIS
EASY WE WANT TO MAKE IT ACCESS
FOR FOR PEOPLE GETTING IN THE
BUSINESS. FOR THEMSELVES AND
MOVING THEM UP THE LADDER SO
SALON AT SOME TIME AND THEN GO
THROUGH THE LICENSING PROCESS OF
COURSE SO NO ONE'S TRYING TO
TAKE THAT AWAY.
A BY REPEALING THESE
REQUIREMENTS S. B. NINE NINE
NINE WOULD INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THESE BILLS.
REDUCE RESTRICTIONS.
AND ON BUSINESS OWNERS AND SET
UP A A POSITIVE ATTITUDE TOWARDS
DEREGULATING CERTAIN OCCUPATIONS
IN THE SPIRIT OF FREE OTHER
ENTERPRISE.
AND LASTLY I I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE WITH THIS THAT THAT WERE I
THINK WERE HARMING PEOPLE IN
THIS ENTRY LEVEL FEEL AND AND WE
WANT TO HELP PEOPLE TO TO CLIMB
THE LADDER OF SUCCESS.
IN AGAIN WITH THESE LICENSING
FEES A FIFTEEN HOURS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS I MEAN --
TO TEST IN UP TO NINETEEN
THOUSAND INTUITION AND MOST
THAT'S PAID THROUGH STUDENT
LOANS IS VERY COSTLY AND SO IT
SEEMS LIKE TO ME.
THE WINNERS HERE ARE THE BARBER --
SCHOOLS MANY BEAUTY SCHOOLS
WHICH I THINK YOU KNOW I'M A
FREE MARKET ECONOMY GUY BUT
AGAIN I THINK WE HAVE TOO MANY
LICENSING.
FEES WE WANT TO MAKE ACCESS EASY
AND SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS AND
HERE TO TESTIFY.
ON THIS MEASURE IS DAVID LEFT
REPRESENTING THE OUR ST
INSTITUTE IF YOU WOULD DAVID YES
IF YOU COULD JUST POSITIVE FROM
OWN SO WE CAN A SUBSEQUENT.
LOW HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
CRITIC YOU'VE IMAGE WE HAVE NOW
IS THAT IS A QUORUM AND UP TO
TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT COUNTY PLEASE PRETTY
PLEASE SIR PRESENTMENT EVERY
READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO
MORNING DAVID WOLF TODAY
REPRESENTING OUR STUDENTS TO
WEAR THE SPONSORS OF S. B..
NINE NINE NINE OUR STUDENTS TO
HEAT IS A NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN
NATIONWIDE THINK TANK
ORGANIZATION THAT SPECIALIZES IN
FREE MARKET INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY
ISSUES.
IS TOPICS COVER A WIDE RANGE OF
INTERESTS RANGING FROM BAYLOR
FARM IN PUBLIC SAFETY TO
ECONOMIST VEHICLES IN THE GIG
ECONOMY AND ESPECIALLY MEMBERS
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY.
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING AS IT
REGARDS VARIOUS APPLICATIONS OF
HER STYLE AND MEMBERS A SENATOR
MERLE NOTED THERE IS IN FACT A
BARRIER TO ENTRY REGARDING HER
STYLING APPLICATIONS LISTED IN
S. B..
NINE NINE NINE RIGHT NOW IF YOU
WANT TO SHARE PREPARE ENGAGING
OTHER DRIVE OUR SERVICES THE
PLACE ZERO REST ON PUBLIC SAFETY
AS SENATOR MORALE MENTION YOU
NEED AT LEAST FIFTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS.
OF EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS IN
NEED TO PASS TWO EXAMS.
MEANWHILE YOU NEED FAR LESS
TRAINING TO BECOME AN EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIAN --
FOR THOSE JUST STARTING OUT OR
WHO WANT TO BASIC JOB A SAWN
SHAMPOOING ARRANGING OR CURLING
HAIR THIS DOES INDEED REPRESENT.
A DIFFICULT BARRIER TO ENTRY.
SOME CONFUSED OUR STREETS
INVOLVEMENT IN S. B. NINE NINE
NINE IS THE FIRST STEP IN A
PROCESS TO UP AND THE BAR
BRINGING COSMETOLOGY CODE
SECTION.
TODAY THEY SAY IT SHAMPOOING
TOMORROW THEY SAID SOMETHING
ELSE.
BUT THAT'S NOT OUR AGENDA
MEMBERS IT COMES DOWN TO A
SIMPLE BUT FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING.
IS THE POINTS TO CREATE A FORMER
PROTECTIONISM THAT ESTABLISHES
THE BARRIER TO ENTRY OR IS THE
GOAL TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE BELIEVE THE FOCUS SHOULD BE
ON THE LATTER WHICH IS WHY HER
CUTTING HAIR DIALING CHEMICAL
PEELS AND A HOST OF OTHER
PROFESSIONS ARE NOT IN THIS BILL.
THE HAIRSTYLING APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE LISTED FOR EXEMPTION S.
B. NINE NINE NINE WERE CAREFULLY
CHOSEN BECAUSE THEY INVOLVE
ABSOLUTE ZERO RISK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
OR OTHER APPLICATIONS LIKE
SHAMPOOING HER CURLING THAT
PEOPLE DO OF PRODUCTS THAT CAN
BE FOUND IN A WALMART.
AGAIN IN CLOSING WE BELIEVE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SPEND A YEAR
OF YOUR LIFE AND NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF CHAMPAGNE AND
STYLING HARRIS CURRENT I'VE UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BISHOP HALL
AND I'M THE STATE POLICY MANAGER
FOR TECHNIQUE.
TECHNET REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
OF THE NATION'S LEADING TECH
COMPANIES WE ARE NATIONAL
BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF NET A OF
TECH CEOS IN SENIOR EXECUTIVES.
THAT PROMOTE THE GROWTH OF THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY AND OUR
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES
DYNAMIC START UPS AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHED COMPANIES.
TOGETHER IMPACTING MORE THAN
THREE MILLION EMPLOYEES.
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SUCH AS BEING NINE NINE NINE AS
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
ACCESS TO WORK ISSUE --
THE BOARD OF OUR BRING IN
COSMETOLOGY HAS STRICT
REGULATIONS IN PLACE ABOUT WHO'S
ALLOWED TO PERFORM DUTY SERVICE
AND WHERE THEY CAN DO IT AND
UNFORTUNATELY THESE RULES
PROHIBIT ANY INNOVATION AND THE
BUSINESS SPACE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE MORE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH MORE SERVICES.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND TO START
THE CONVERSATION AND REFORMING
OLD STATUTES IN ORDER TO PROMOTE
NEW AND INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES.
WE ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
THINKING.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT WILL NOW THEN ASK
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
THEREFORE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WILL ALLOW FOR UP TO TWO
WITNESSES TO COME TO THE PODIUM
HERE AND UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEN FOR THE REST OF ALSO
COME FOR A ME TOO A FEEL FREE TO
LINE UP THE A MICROPHONE WHEN
READY SO AGAIN.
UMBEL ALLOW FOR UP [inaudible]
TO TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CARY WILLIAMS
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE BORDER BARRING A COSMETOLOGY
Y. CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT.
HAVE A DOCTORATE IN PSYCHOLOGY
WHICH IS A BRANCH OF THEIR
MENTALITY THAT FOCUSES ON THE
SCIENTIFIC STUDY OF HARRIS OUT
DISORDERS.
I'M A LICENSED BARBER HERE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS AS WELL AS A SALON OWNER
IN BEVERLY HILLS CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'D TAKEN OPPOSED POSITION
ON S. B. NINETY NINE OUT BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT Y..
I AM I AM HERE AS A WITNESS THAT
HAVING A LICENSE IN THIS
INDUSTRY HAS AFFORDED ME SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
I AM I HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH A NUMBER OF
CELEBRITY CLIENTS AS WELL AS
TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD AS A
RESULT OF MY LIFE THINGS --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BORDER
BOBBING COSMETOLOGY THAT.
WE DO NOT HAVE PARTISAN VERY
BURDENSOME BARRIERS TO ENTRY ARE
STATE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT HAS
ENCOURAGED MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA TO PURSUE THIS
VIBRANT INDUSTRY AND ESTABLISH
LIFE LONG CAREERS --
A NUMBER OF ISSUES ARE PRESENTED
IT IS GOING TO SHAMPOO PROCESS
THAT WE ACTUALLY ASSESSED TO
HELP IN.
THE HEALTH OF A CLIENT HERE AND
SCOUT IT IS HERE THAT WE DETECT
WHERE WE DETERMINE AND IDENTIFY
COMMON SCALP DISORDERS LIKE
DANDRUFF.
AND BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHICH
PRODUCTS IN THE INGREDIENTS IN
THOSE PRODUCTS BUT HELP US TO
SERVE OUR CLIENTS I THINK THE
MISTAKE THAT OF THE MAKE IT THAT
IS BEING MADE HERE IS THAT
SAMPLING IS NOT IT ALA CARTE
SERVICE BUT IT IS A PART OF IT.
OF A COMPLETE SERVICE.
TYPICALLY CLIENTS DO NOT COME
INTO THE SALON AND REQUEST
SHAMPOO ONLY AS A SERVICE IT IS
PART OF A SHAMPOO BLOW DRY
SERVICE IT IS A PART OF A COLOR
SERVICE INTO THE PART OF RELAX
OR SERVICE.
SO WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IT WILL
INCREASE UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY IN OUR ON DEMAND
SOCIETY AND NUMBER OF CLIENTS
ARE NOW SAVING TIME IN THE SALON.
BY SHAMPOOING THEIR HAIR AT
CLIENTS COME INTO THE SLIME
REQUESTING THE SERVICE
[inaudible]
ALONE.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
ANY MONEY TO BE MADE IN THE
BUSINESS OF SAMPLING OF A LOT OF
LARGE CHAINS WANTS NO LONGER
OFFER THE SERVICE LIKE DR BARS
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD CURRENTLY
HAS OVER SIX HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LICENSEES WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND OF THOSE BEING LICENSE
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF WE HAVE
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS TO INTRUDE
INTO THIS INDUSTRY AS A RESULT
WE DO NOT BELIEVE WE HAVE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY.
INDIVIDUALS CAN ATTEND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE
BEGINNING APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
WHERE INDIVIDUALS CAN EARN AN
INCOME WHILE OBTAINING ON THE
JOB TRAINING.
IT SUPPORTS ALSO KNOW THAT THE
NATIONAL INTERSTATE COUNCIL
WHICH PROVIDES OUR EXAM FOR
LICENSEES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT IF
WE LOSE THESE PROCEDURES WE
CANNOT PROVIDE THE TEST TO OUR
LICENSEES BECAUSE THIS IS AN
INTRAPARTY OF OUR EXAM.
AND THIS WILL THREATEN OUR STATE
TO STATE RECIPROCITY.
YOU VERY MUCH --
AS NO ONE USES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS SUE CABRAL EVERT AND
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF IATSE
LOCAL SEVEN NO.
SIX THE UNION THAT PRETTY
CREATES THE CHARACTERS YOU WATCH
ON FILM AND TELEVISION.
OR GIVE HUGS HUGS TO AT
DISNEYLAND.
SENATE BILL NINE NINE NINE MAY
SEEM ON PRESENTATION BE HARMLESS
TO THE CONSUMER.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO EMPLOY
A HIGHLY SKILLED COSMETOLOGY
LICENSED HAIR STYLIST.
IN THE FILM AND TELEVISION
INDUSTRY AND AT THE DISNEYLAND
RESORT.
IN OUR IATSE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THE A BASIC
AGREEMENT THE NETWORK TELEVISION.
AND THE DISNEYLAND RESORT
AGREEMENTS IT IS REQUIRED THAT.
ELIGIBILITY FOR UNION MEMBERSHIP
OR PLACEMENT ON THE PRODUCERS
INDUSTRY EXPERIENCED ROSTER
REQUIRES A FULL COSMETOLOGY
LICENSE.
BARBOUR LICENSES ARE NOT ALLOWED
WITHIN THE CBA HOWEVER
COSMETOLOGY LICENSES FROM OTHER
STATES AND CERTIFICATIONS.
AND EVEN OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
PERMITTED.
EVEN THOUGH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES EXEMPTS THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY FROM THE
COSMETOLOGY REQUIREMENT.
THE UNION CBA'S FOR FILM
TELEVISION AND DISNEY LAND ALL
REQUIRE A LICENSE OR EMPLOYERS
HAVE AN EXPECTATION OF TRAINING.
PROVIDED BY THE COSMETOLOGY ACT
TO SAFEGUARD OUR INDUSTRY AND
THOSE QUALIFICATIONS HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE FOR DECADES.
WE RELY ON THAT EDUCATION AS A
FOUNDATION.
WITHIN FILM AND TELEVISION WE
ALSO ACCEPT COSMETOLOGY LICENSES
FROM OTHER AREAS.
BUT THEY MUST HAVE EQUAL
EDUCATION.
AND IF IT PUTS OUR CALIFORNIA
HAIRSTYLISTS AT RISK THEY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO WORK.
OR MOVE AROUND OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU COULD KIND THE AWESOME
RISE ONE SECOND YES.
ON THE OUTSIDE THE BALLOT THE
THIS BILL DEVALUES THE BASIC
FOUNDATION OF THE CRAFTER
HAIRSTYLING.
OUR UNION COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT REQUIRES AND FOR
ENTRANCE INTO OUR GUILD.
COULD BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS ACTION
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE MAKE UP
ARTISTS AND HAIR STYLISTS GUILD
IATSE LOCAL SEVEN NO.
SIX WE STAND WITH THEIR SISTERS
AND BROTHERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD COSMETOLOGY THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY ASSOCIATION.
AND CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND SINCERELY REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE NO ON SB.
NINE NINE NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
NAME AND AFFILIATION SIMPLY IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF
THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
SERAPH LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIDGET SHARP AT
THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
INFERNO VOTE THANK YOU.
MAP BACK REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
IN OPPOSITION.
DEBORAH HAULING SAID ON BEHALF
OF SALON CENTRIC A WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTOR --
HOUSE FOR YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROGER DEAN I'M A BARBER STUDENT
AT FEDERICO CURRENTLY I AM ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF LOCAL NINETY
FOUR THIRTY ONE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA.
AND MY WIFE IS A POSITION.
AND WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS BILL AT
LENGTH.
AND WE OPPOSE IT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY REASONS.
YOU TOUCH PEOPLE YOU TRANSFER
DISEASES.
IF YOU DO THAT AT HOME.
IT'S WITH YOUR OWN CHILDREN WITH
THE PUBLIC YOUR MUCH LATELY
DIFFERENCE ST YOU THANK YOU.
ARIANNA OLEWNICK FROM FEDERICO
BEAUTY INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION.
CONCEPCION WEST AND FEDERICO
PENA INSTITUTE OPPOSE.
KATHY JACOBS INSPIRE ACADEMY OF
BARBERING IN COSMETOLOGY AND
STOPPED AND OPPOSED.
VERY I GET FAR WITH INSPIRE CAO
TO ME OPPOSED.
A PROGRESS EFUTURE PROFESSIONAL --
FROM GULPED AND I OPPOSE.
SAMANTHA GARCIA ON FROM CALL
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
JULIE COLEMAN FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
MELISSA MENCHACA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I UP.
RACHEL ROSEN FROM AUBURN AND I
OPPOSE.
MARY JO CROP FROM WILLING
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
SOLEDAD MAN THIS FIRM ROOSEVELT
CALIFORNIA I'M A FEDERICO
GRADUATE AND I'M --
PAUL MITCHELL EDUCATOR AND I
CAN'T EXPRESS HOW MUCH.
IT TAKES A NAIVE PERSON TO THINK
THAT. TO DEAL WITH A PERSON
SCALP HAIR WHICH HE YOU DON'T
NEED A LICENSE YOU NEED TO SEE
THE BIGGER PICTURE [inaudible]
I OPPOSE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
EILEEN LIONS SO LOAN OR KNOW UP
ON SCHOOL OR NAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SON WAS THE RESIDENT
AND SCHOOL OWN --
IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
D. CROSS THAT DEAN OF THE
SERVICES GO INSTITUTED A SUFFIX
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE RESTITUTION
FORMER --
BORDER BERMAN COSMETOLOGY
PRESIDENT INCORRECT MEMBER THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE --
THIS BILL AND I ASK YOU THE SAME
THINKS.
GOOD MORNING I'M CHARL SNODGRASS
SALON OWNERS SYMPATHETIC.
AND I OPPOSE.
DEJA OWENS FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
I LIKE THE HALF THE SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND NIGHT POPES.
THESE ARE SEE MORE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND FEDERICO
OBEDIENCE IT HERE AND I OPPOSE.
RICHARD JONES WITH FEDERICO
OBEDIENCE TO AND I'VE CLOSE.
VICTORIA TERRACE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIAN I POST.
SMALL NOVEL FROM CENTERS A
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
MONIQUE AROUND LICENSE
COSMETOLOGIST AND ALSO LEARNING
LEADER.
AND CITY OF THE THOMAS AND I
OPPOSE --
CARING AND BAILEY EDUCATION
WINTER UPON MUCH OF THE SCHOOL
SACRAMENTO I DON'T THINK THAT
YOU SHOULD UNDER MIND --
SOMETHING THAT TAKES A TECHNICAL
SKILL SUCH A SHAMPOOING I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING SHAUNA HALL LICENSE
ESTHETICIAN EDUCATOR AT SFI SEE
IN SAN FRANCISCO ALSO A FORMER
SALON OWNER IN NAPA COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CALLING JOB FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AN EMPLOYEE AT THE
SIMS IS GOING STATISTICS IN
COSMETOLOGY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING TONY COMMENT FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO INSTITUTE OF
AESTHETICS AND HOUSE MENTALITY A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL NATURALLY
OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
JOHNSON SERVICES WITH A TO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MARINA CAME FROM CARMICHAEL AND
I POLLS.
JOHNSON HAD SO FUTURE
PROFESSIONAL FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
TAYLOR ASKING YOU FROM THE
THOMAS CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
MARY BERNARD FROM CHICO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ROGER HUTCHINSON'S FEDERICO
BEAUTY INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE.
HE HONESTLY S. FROM SALINAS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SHOWING US --
MONDAY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
YEAH THEY'VE SERMON A CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE.
DEJA PARDEW FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I POSE.
BRISTOL BENTLEY FROM EL DORADO
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
KELLY KEEGAN REGISTERED TO VOTE
IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
EMPLOYED IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
ALSO OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING CREDIT CLOSE A
UNLICENSED PROFESSIONAL SALON
OWNER BEAUTY SCHOOL COSMETOLOGY
MARK AS A CATERED I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ANGELA COLLINS I'M
FUTURE COSMETOLOGIST I OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING OF WANT TO GO SEE A
BARBER STUDENT I POSE.
MICHELLE GONZALEZ CURRENT
STUDENT FEDERICO STILL AYE
SHOWING THE POSTS.
MARIA CISNEROS FROM FEDERICO
BEAUTY INSISTED AND I WAS.
GOOD MORNING AND TREASURE OF LOS
EDUCATOR BATTERY COOKIE
INSTITUTE I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JAMES FEDERICO WITH FEDERICO
BEAUTY INSTITUTE AND I OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING I'M A FREE TO
CALDWELL WITH FEDERICO PENA
INSTITUTE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MORNING I'M ROMANTIC CHRIS FROM
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE.
MEGAN MARTIN SALON OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SYDNEY STARES FROM FEDERICO
OBEDIENCE TO S. STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BILLY WINN FROM THEATER FEDERICO
BDS TINASHE STRONG OPPOSE.
ACTUALLY SILVA FROM BETTER GOPI
INSTITUTE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MORRELL OPPOSE FROM FEDERICO
BEAUTY INSTITUTE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
THE TIRE RECENT FROM FEDERICO
BILLION SITTING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
MY NAME'S KAREN I KNOW ITS --
THIS IS MY EDUCATION THIS IS MY
PASSION AND I PAID FOR THIS AND
I REALLY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SQUARE ROOTS HAVE FEDERICO PD
INSTITUTE CITY OF AUBURN I
OPPOSE.
SO IN THE CASE OF FEDERICO
OBEDIENCE TO AN EXTRA POSTS.
CLAUDIA MILAN WITH RAY TO BE IN
CITY WHEN I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BECAUSE IT TEARS FROM THREE
COULD BE INTO NICE ON THE POST --
MADLY BACK FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY --
AYE OPPOSE IT ALSO LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT --
THE SAME TRAINING THAT I GOT
HERE FEDERICO SO IT IDENTIFY
SCALP AND SKIN CONDITIONS HAS
BEEN COMPARABLE TO THE SAME
TRAINING I RECEIVED IN THE
MILITARY.
THANK YOU.
COURTNEY FUND STUDENT FREDERICK
OBEDIENCE YOU FROM BREAST Y.
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
REBEKAH MENTOR AND THE
PROFESSIONAL AND WITH FEDERICO
SPEEDY SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE.
GET REALLY REMEMBERS FROM
FEDERICO ANAYA POST.
MELISSA CASTILLO OF FEDERATED
FEDERICO MILLION TO TWO AND A
HALF POLLS.
OLIVIA APPEAR* FEDERICO PENA
IS IT TOO AND I OPPOSE.
KAREN CALDERON CO OWNER OF A SO
ON AND YUBA CITY CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE.
MAGGIE BLAIR FROM THE THOMAS AND
MY NAME IS DOMINIQUE I'M FROM
FEDERICO AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS KATHY LEMOND'S I AM
AN EDUCATOR AT BETTER RECALLS
AND I OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS BERNICE CAMINO
I AM CURRENTLY A FEDERICO BEAUTY
COLLEGE STUDENT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU DO
THE SAME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KILEY CONTRAST NOT THOMAS AND I
OPPOSE.
A LESSER AMOUNT AYE FROM OUT ON
HEALTH CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
KELLY GETS FROM DICK'S IN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
MICHELLE DELUDE US SO FROM OF
GROWTH AND I'M OPPOSE.
GRAY IS FROM AS WELL CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE.
CAROLINE OR IS FROM FEDERICO BT
INSTITUTE I OPPOSE.
ARI TONER FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
HI I'M JEREMY FEDERICO PRESIDENT
A FEDERAL FEDERICO BEAUTY
INSTITUTE.
INDEPENDENT THINKER.
AND I UP OPPOSED STRONGLY ALL
THE STUDENTS THAT COME WITH US
TODAY WE HAD DIALOGUE AROUND
THIS NONE OF THEM ARE COERCED.
EVERYBODY'S EXPRESSING THEIR OWN
FREE WILL STRONGLY OPPOSE WE'RE
IN THE PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT
BUSINESS AND I APPLAUD THEM.
FOR DOING THEIR CIVIC.
DUTY THANK YOU.
WE CARRY CANCEL FROM SACRAMENTO
ANY DO A REGULATORY COMPLIANCE
FOR POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS AND I
AM ALSO PROCESS THINK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LISA SOUTH RITA
FEATURE SALON OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HELLO MANY WAS HAROON OF ADDRESS
BOTH IN SACRAMENTO TYPOS.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE ASORIO AND
I THINK THERE'S A LOT TO BE
LEARNED IN THIS INDUSTRY AND I
POST.
HI I'M GERRY FEDERICO I'M
RETIRED --
BUT I I DO OPPOSE AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY THAT I SUPPOSE
ALL RIGHT ALONG WITH US THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT JUST
KNOW IF I COULD ASK YOU.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF AT ANY
ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO DISH NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
NOW FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
ROOM WOMAN BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATOR I THINK HE DEFTLY
HAVE THE RIGHT GOAL AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT I APPRECIATE
GETTING.
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY THIS WITH
YOU ABOUT THE BILL AND THEY
BARRIERS THAT OUR STATE PUTS
FORWARD BOTH IN TERMS OF COST
AND TIME TO ENTER.
LIVELIHOOD AND ENTERPRISE --
I DO HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT AND I JUST WANT --
TO GIVEN OPPORTUNITY.
TO DETAIL AND WITH IT THE YOU
MENTION THE TUITION IS EXPENSIVE
IN THIS IS A BIG PART OF IT THE
BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THAT POINT
AND I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THERE IS IN MY VIEW A
PURPOSE TO THE TRAINING I
VISITED WITH FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT BOTH APOLO DRIVE BARS.
WHERE IT'S NOT ANY CUTTING OR
OTHER --
ACTUAL ANYTHING OTHER THAN
SHAMPOOING IN A VARIETY OF
STYLING THERE'S NO CUTTING.
AND AND IN SALONS WHERE THEY'VE
HAD TO HAVE THE FULL TRAINING
THERE'S A PURPOSE TO THE
TRAINING THAT'S BEYOND --
BEING ABLE TO BLOW DRY NICELY IF
YOU'VE BEEN TO APPLE DRIVE OUR
WERE THAT'S ALL THEY DO YOU.
AS IT LOOKED LIKE I COULD HAVE
DONE WELL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
I I HAVE.
I I I DON'T HAVE AS MUCH HERE AS
I THAT I HAVE I GOT TODAY PROP
QUITE OBVIOUSLY NOT TODAY BUT
AYE I I HAVE.
AND KNOW THAT THEY ARE.
TOUCHING YOU YOUR SCALP YOUR
SKIN YOUR HAIR THE TRAINING IS
NOT ONLY FOR IDENTIFYING
POTENTIAL HOW TO BE EITHER MORE
GENTLE OR OTHERWISE ADDRESS THE
SCALP BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A
CURLING IRON YOU WANT THE PURSE.
SURE THEY DON'T BURN YOU TO BURN
YOUR HAIR TO BURN YOUR SKIN TO
BRING YOUR FACE.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE TRAINING
THAT COMES FROM THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS.
AND AND THE SANITATION OF COURSE
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
A LICENSED A LICENSE HOLDER WILL
OWN THE BUSINESS IN HIS HAVE THE
TRAIN ON THE VISITOR.
ANY OPENNESS TO REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO TRAIN THEIR
EMPLOYEES ON THAT [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
I'M.
YEARS AGO I I DON'T A NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES [inaudible]
AND I YOU NOTICE THEY ARE
REQUIRED LICENSE WHERE THEY HAD
TRAINING ONE THING I NOTICE --
GOING TO SCHOOL GET NEAR REAL
ESTATE LICENSE OR YOUR LAND THE
LICENSE I HAVE A LENDING COMPANY
THAT DIDN'T MAKE YOUR
PROFESSIONAL WE ALWAYS HAD
ONGOING TRAINING.
I LEARNED THAT EARLY ON THAT
THAT YOU DON'T DEPEND ON JUST
GET THE LICENSE TAKEN A CLASS.
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
GOOD SUPERVISION AARON AND
LIFE'S CONSTANTLY ON GOING
TRAINING AND THAT'S WHAT.
I THINK MAKES FOR A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSES AND SO ON IT'S A
LICENSE DOESN'T MAKE.
A A PEOPLE PROP UP ONE OF THAT
THE THINKS AGAIN THAT I I JUST
WANT TO STRESS WERE JUST TRYING
TO MAKE THIS EASY ACCESS
[inaudible]
AND AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT'S
ALL ABOUT BUT ONE ONE THING THAT
SORT OF ALARMS ME IS THIS YOUNG
LADY HERE ARTICULATED I WROTE IT
DOWN.
SHE SAID THERE'S NO MONEY TO BE
MADE AND SHAMPOOING PAMBA YET
AGAIN WERE MAKING IT VERY HARD
WITH.
THE LICENSEE HANNAH AND HER
TUITION THAT KIND THANKS SO
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT REALLY CONCERN ME.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE WANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL IN OUR STATE
AND IN AGAIN YOU KNOW THE HIGH
THE HOOVER INSTITUTE SAID DID
THE LARGEST DOWN ONE OF THE
LARGEST DEMOGRAPHICS OF PEOPLE
EVEN OUR STATE.
ARE HIGHLY EDUCATED YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS BETWEEN TWENTY
FIVE AND THIRTY NINE WERE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA FOR GREENER
PASTURES AND AGAIN YOU KNOW THAT.
TOP FIVE HUNDRED SEALS TWELVE
YEARS AND LOCAL PLACES DO
BUSINESS AND IT ISN'T JUST HIGH
TAXES NUMBER ONE IS REGULATORY
STATE AND SO HAPPY THAT THIS
JUST STANDS IN THE WAY.
AGAIN THE PEOPLE ON OPPORTUNITY
AT A VERY PRICEY.
THING AND SO FAR IS THAT CURLING
IRON THING I CAN'T ARGUE WITH
YOU THERE BUT MY GOODNESS --
I'VE BEEN MARRIED GOING ON FORTY
ONE YEARS AND MY WIFE.
USES A CURLING IRON MOST DAYS
AND I DON'T KNOW SHE'S EVER HAD
A PROBLEM I DON'T.
YOU KNOW I MEAN I CAN ASK SOME
YOU GUYS OUT BUT WELL I CAN
ANSWER THAT FOR YOU SO --
IT'S IT'S SAYING THAT IF YOU
RAISE I MEAN I KNOW WE DON'T
GOVERN BY ANECDOTES THAT WAY BUT
I HAD IT IS EASY TO BURN
YOURSELF YEAH ON IT IF YOU DO IT
EVERY DAY AND TO TO TO HURT
ONESELF BECAUSE THIS IS.
SOMETHING WHERE YOUR BODY IS
INVOLVED THAT'S RIGHT.
I GUESS MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
BILL IS IT A COMPLETELY GETS RID
OF ANY TRAINING OR LICENSING AND
WE'VE HAD EFFORTS THAT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE DURING THE SUNSET
PROCESS OF OF OF PERHAPS HAVING
STEPS I THINK IT WITH ATHLETIC
TRAINERS WE'VE CHANGED THAT
THERE DOES HAVE TO BE A FULL.
LICENSE BUT THERE CAN BE.
A A CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS
REQUIRED SO THAT THE PERSON
WHO'S GONNA BE TOUCHING ANOTHER
PERSON'S BODY.
AND HAVING INSTRUMENTS AROUND
THEM HAS TO HAVE.
SOME MINIMUM AMOUNT OF OF
TRAINING ASIDE FROM THE
SANITATION I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WOULD BE OPEN TO THAT WELL.
THAT WOULD BE THE RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE SALON OWNER.
I MEAN TO BE TRAINING.
THERE PEOPLE ARE YOU KNOW JUST
TO SHAMPOO AND A WATCH OUT FOR
THOSE THINGS ON A REGULAR BASIS
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE.
OFFICE MEETINGS AT LEAST ONCE A
WEEK AND THAT TYPE OF THING.
AND SO AGAIN I I THINK IT'S OVER
KILL.
ON THE LICENSING BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS I SAID IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT IS MY STAFF --
EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT HERE THEY
LET THE FORTY HAIR SALONS AND
THERE WAS REALLY NO COMPLAINTS
THAT THERE WERE TWO OUT OF THE
HUNDREDS THAT WE SEARCH --
NUMBER WAS ON BEING BURNED BY
CURLING IRON --
OR BAD SHAMPOOING BUT AGAIN WE
DID FIND HUNDREDS OF OF PEOPLE
HAD BAD HAIR CUTS AND WERE
UNHAPPY WITHOUT KNOWS OUR
LICENSE PEOPLE THAT'S ON TRYING.
TO NOT NOT RANKING ON ANY
PROFESSION HERE I'M JUST SAYING
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA WE MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
COMPETE THIS IS A HUGE BARRIER
OF THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY. FOR
THE ENTER THIS FIELD SO AGAIN
IT'S ABOUT ACCESS.
I'M I I THINK YOU MAKE SOME VERY
GOOD POINTS I WITH THE
LEGISLATION EVEN IN THE BURDEN
THAT CALIFORNIA IS AND I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR EFFORT TO
TAKE A CRACK AT IT IN THIS WHEN
I FRIENDLY ENCOURAGEMENT THAT
THERE MAY BE AT IN BETWEEN
MEASURE THAT WE MIGHT --
TAKE IF THIS.
IT HAS TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
WHICH IS A PART OF THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL.
AND INVITE YOU TO COME TO MY
DISTRICT IN AND VISIT THE THE
BOTH THE BLOW DRY SALONS AND
OTHERWISE THAT ARE AND ARE DOING
A GREAT JOB.
AND SOMEONE IS ABLE TO LEAVE
UNHARMED AND WELL TAKEN CARE OF
BUT THEM I THINK YOU FOR
TACKLING THE ISSUE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO DO --
AND HOPE THERE CAN BE AN IN
BETWEEN MEASURE PERHAPS IN IN
THE FUTURE THINK LONGEST CLOUT I
GOT HERE THIS MORNING THOUGHT
THIS BILL WOULD BE CONTENTIOUS
AND IT'S NOT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
SENATOR MORRELL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
ISSUE BECAUSE IT.
DEALS WITH THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN --
TO IDEAS THAT OUR INTENTION THE
IDEA OF REGULATION AND THE IDEA
OF PROTECTION OF OUR CONSUMER
SAFETY SO.
I I I THINK IT'S A VERY
MEANINGFUL BUILT --
I I WOULD AGREE WITH TECH NET I
THINK THAT.
THE CURRENT REGULATORY STRUCTURE
IS -- TOO
RIGID AND THAT IT BLOCKS
INNOVATION IN THIS FIELD AND I
WANNA REMIND EVERYONE THAT WHEN
WE STAND IN THE WAY OF
INNOVATION AND BUSINESS MODELS.
ARE THE CONSUMER IS THE ONE THAT
SUFFERS.
RIGHT THAT WE WE WE HAVE TO
WORLD YOU KNOW A A WORLD WHERE
WE ARE ALLOW INNOVATION IN A
WORLD WHERE WE DON'T AND WE'RE
WHEN WE'RE ALLOWING INNOVATION
THAT MEANS PEOPLE CAN GET
SERVICES THEY WANT --
IN IN WAYS THAT ARE EASIER FOR
THEM AND WAYS THAT COST THEM
LESS MONEY SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION
AND STILL PROTECT CONSUMER
SAFETY I THINK WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION. TO CALIFORNIANS TO
DO THAT AND I THINK THAT YOUR
BILL MOVES US IN THAT DIRECTION
I'LL CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY.
BUT I WANT TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
THAT SHOULD THE BILL NOT MOVE
FORWARD TO THAT THIS NOT BE THE
END OF THE DISCUSSION BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BOARD HAS
BEEN CONSIDERING --
A PERSONAL SERVICES PERMIT THAT
WOULD PERMIT A NARROW RANGE OF
SERVICES OUTSIDE OF THE SETTING
A PHYSICAL SO ON I THINK THAT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT THING. FOR THEM
TO BE CONSIDERING AND ESPECIALLY
AS WE'RE MOVING INTO THE SUNSET
REVIEW NEXT YEAR.
I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE SECONDS
PROPOSITION TO CONTINUE SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD SENATORS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SETTLING ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN.
YEAH I AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID TODAY I
I THINK YOU BRING UP SOME VERY
GOOD POINTS AND AND CERTAINLY WE
DON'T WANT OVER REGULATION.
A BARRIER TO ENTRY [inaudible]
OF BUT I DO THINK THAT THE MORE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO EXPLORE THIS
SUBJECT FURTHER IS AND DURING
THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS BUT I
I I THINK YOU NEED TO CONTINUE
ON THIS SUBJECT.
BUT TODAY I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL BUT APPRECIATE --
THE DISCUSS.
YOUR YOU KNOW BY THE WAY ON THE
SUNSET THE WAY.
I'VE SEEN SHORT TIME I'VE BEEN
IN.
SACRAMENTO WHICH HAS BEEN I
PASSED MY SEVEN HERE --
FEW THINGS EVER GET SUNSET AND
SO THIS IS THIS IS HERE AND NOW
I WANT TO PROVIDE MORE JOBS FOR
PEOPLE.
MAKE IT EASIER ACCESS IN AGAIN
YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST.
GOT IN THE MY BUSINESS YEARS AGO
IT WAS FINE YOU NEED JUST ONE
LICENSE YOU KNOW AND THEN YOU
CAN GO AND DO DEALS AND AND OVER
THE YEARS JUST MORE COMPLIANCE
MORE COMPLIANCE.
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT AND TODAY
NUMBER PEOPLE GOTTEN OUT OF THAT
THE TRADE I WAS IN AND AND SO
CALIFORNIA NO GOVERNMENT.
IS SUPPOSED TO ARE NOT STIFLE
PRO BUT PRODUCTIVITY BUT
SUPPOSED TO FOSTER IT AND THESE
ARE HUGE HURDLES.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS IS MY FRIEND --
FROM BIG BEAR CITED OUT IT DOES
DRIVE THE PRICE UP FOR CONSUMER
WITH THIS KIND A LICENSING
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE.
TO CHARGE MORE AND AND NOT AIR
YOU KNOW MY SON IN LAW NOW CUTS
[inaudible]
HIS [inaudible]
BOYS HAIR.
HE DOESN'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB BY
THE WAY BUT BUT NEVERTHELESS YOU
KNOW THERE THERE THERE ON A
TIGHT.
THERE ON A TIGHT.
SCOPE AND AND THEY HAVE TO DO IT
BECAUSE THINGS ARE JUST PRICEY
AND AND SO --
YOU KNOW THAT IT DOES PUSH
PEOPLE.
OUT OF OUR BEING AND GET THOSE
HAIRCUTS BUT THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
ITS IS SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AT THIS TIME AT SENATOR MORAL DO
WISH TO CLOSE.
YES IT HEY LOOK IT --
A GOOD DISCUSSION PRECIADO
REBUTTING THE AUDIENCE AYE I
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE
COMING FROM --
IN AGAIN HIGH AND I'M JUST
TRYING -- TO
HAVE GOVERNMENT WORK FORCE NOT
AGAINST US AND BE THERE TO BE
OUR SERVANT NOT OUR MASTER.
AND REMOVE SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS THAT --
YOU NO HELP US THE THRIVE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE TOP FIVE STATES.
ARM RIGHT NOW THAT ARE THRIVING
ECONOMICALLY --
YA ON EMPIRICAL DATA AND
EVIDENCE IT'S IT'S STATES THAT
ARE REMOVING THESE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY AND SO --
THAT'S WHAT I WAS BORN AND
RAISED HERE RAISE OUR FAMILY
HERE AND I WANT CALIFORNIA TO BE
RESTORED BACK WHERE THERE'S
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY SO WITH
THAT. ONE THANK YOU GUYS FOR FOR
GOOD DISCUSSION AND HONEST
DISCUSSION.
AND THE COURSE --
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AS AN UMBRELLA.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY IN
YOUR PASSION IN THIS ISSUE.
AS YOU KNOW YOU AND I HAVE A
SHARED A DISCUSSION AS WELL AS
OUR RESPECTIVE STAFFS IN TRYING
TO COOPERATE.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED.
NOW WE HAVE ALSO ARTICULATED
THAT WE ARE RECOGNIZED THE
IMPENDING SUNSET IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND THAT PERHAPS IT MIGHT
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO INCORPORATE
SOME OF THE POLICY CHANGES AND
THEY DISCUSSIONS.
AND A FULL SUNSET HEARING IN
WHICH WE CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ALL KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IN PRESENT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE AN OPEN DOLLAR CAN
DISCUSSION --
AS YOU ALSO MAY HAVE SEEN IN
SOME OF THE POLICY A CHALLENGES
OF FOR EXAMPLE OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN A ROUGHLY ONE
THIRD OF CONSUMERS --
HAVE HAD A FARM ALLEGATIONS
INVOLVING SOME OF THE BURNS AND
IS SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
CAN RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU WANT TO ADDRESS.
A WHILE ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
AND SO -- WE
ARE EQUALLY A COMMITTED TO
HELPING ADDRESS SOME OF THE
BALANCING CHALLENGES AHEAD OF US
WITH RESPECT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE INVOLVED --
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR MEMBERS
WHO HAVE COME HERE --
TO SPEND SOME TIME WITH US IN
OUR BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
TO HELP PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE YOUR INPUT --
PERHAPS YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
LEAVE THIS COMMITTEE HEARINGS
SHORTLY THEREAFTER TO HELP MAKE
MEMBERS OF THE INSTITUTION LOOK
VERY GOOD.
I'M PROVIDING SOME OF YOUR
SERVICES WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TIME THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED --
HERE AS WELL --
HAVING SAID THAT AGAIN CENTER
ONLY GIVEN THE TIMING OF OUR
UPCOMING A SUNSET UNFORTUNATELY.
WE DO HAVE AND NO RECOMMENDATION
AT HAND A BUT YET WE WANT TO
RESPECT THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND HOPE THAT
WE WILL ACCOMMODATE SOME OF THE
ISSUES OUTLINED IN THIS
DISCUSSION.
AT THE UPCOMING SINCE IT HEARING --
WITH THAT OF THERE IS A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
THOUGHT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DAY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW NO LOW NO
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM NOW JOHN.
CHEN AYE JAIL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
FONG UP VOTING.
GIPSON.
GIPSON NOW GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NO HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NO MEDINA.
MEDINA NO MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THAT VOTE IS A THREE THAT I IN
SEVEN NO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MORRELL --
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT --
ITEM AND WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO
FILE ORDER.
AND THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS S. B. SEVEN NINETY FIVE
SENATOR GALGIANI.
SENATOR GALGIANI THIS DOES HAVE
BEEN AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION AND
I WITH THE MAN'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MERCED
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING ALL
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS AND
THANK THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL.
SB SEVEN NINE FIVE IS A
TECHNICAL MEASURE WITH THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF REMOVING THE
SUNSET DATE FOR THE CURRENT
PRACTICE PRIVILEGED REQUIREMENTS.
FOR OUT OF STATE CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT LICENSEES WHO
ARE CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO PASS
S. IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL WOULD STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS BY WHICH THAT CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY CAN READ
MEDI ANOTHER STATE TO A STATUS
WHICH REQUIRES THAT STATE
LICENSEES. TO PROVIDE NOTICE OF
THEIR PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD ANOTHER STATES
ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES EVER BE
FOUND TO BE.
INADEQUATE.
SIMILARLY THE PROCESS FOR
RESTORING STATE STATUS IS ALSO
STREAMLINED.
SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE ESSENTIAL
EXTENDS WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE
MOBILITY PROGRAM ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED BY SB FOURTEEN OH
FIVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE UNDER THE
MOBILITY PROGRAM CPA'S CAN
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
SERVE CLIENTS ACROSS STATE LINES
WITHOUT UNNECESSARY DELAYS.
AN IMPORTANT BENEFIT GIVEN THE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE NATURE OF
MANY CPA CLIENTS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WITNESS JOSE CAMPOS CHAIR
THE MOBILITY STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE THOSE LAWS THAT BILL.
THERE'S BEEN MOTION A SECOND AND
UP TO TWO MINUTES AGAIN THIS IS
AN AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOSE COMPOST
I AM A CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANT A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
AND THE CURRENT CHAIRMAN.
OF OUR MOBILITY STAKEHOLDER
GROUP WHICH IS THE BOARD'S
COMMITTEE.
CHARGED WITH HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT AND ADMINISTER THE
MOBILITY PROGRAM.
THE BOARD SUPPORTS SP SEVEN
NINETY FIVE AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED TODAY.
THE BOARD BELIEVES THIS PROGRAM
IS GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMERS AND THAT IT HAS
INCREASED THE AMOUNT OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS STATES HAVE UPDATED THEIR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO MEET
OUR APPROVED STANDARDS OF
ENFORCEMENT.
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
TO SENATOR GALGIANI THE
COMMITTEE AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR EFFORTS
TO MAKE BOARDS MOBILITY PROGRAM
PERMANENT.
THANK YOU.
JON ROSS ON BEHALF OF PWC
WHY GRANT THORTON THE LATE AND
KPMG IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JIM GROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
SEEN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO QUESTION
THE CALMEST SENATOR GALGIANI IF
YOU WISH TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU ABOUT THAT YOU VERY MUCH
DESERVED IN MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DID PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE
VOEPEL.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM I JOHN.
JOHN I JAIL CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OF AN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
THE GALGIANI WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN WHICH IS S. B. TWELVE NINETY
FOUR BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
CENTER BRADFORD WELCOME THANK
YOU MISSED YOUR MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT --
SP -- TWELVE
NINETY FOUR WHICH IS TO CANNABIS
COLLABORATION INCLUSION ACT
WHICH WILL ENABLE INDIVIDUALS
FROM DIVERSE.
BACKGROUNDS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIA'S RECENT LEGALIZE
ADULT USE CANNABIS INDUSTRY A
BURGEONING INDUSTRY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR WILL
HELP ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
CREATING AN EQUITABLE INDUSTRY
BY PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND TRAINING TO LOCAL APPLICANTS
AS WELL AS REQUIRING THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO CREATE A
STATE TASK FORCE TO ADVISE TO BE
YOUR RURAL ON DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING.
A STATEWIDE EQUITY PROGRAM
CITIES SUCH AS OAKLAND SAN
FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE CREATED THEIR
OWN EQUITY PROGRAM WHICH FOCUSES
ON INCLUSION IN SUPPORT FOR
APPLICATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN.
AND APPLICANTS I SHOULD SAY THAT
HAVE BEEN HARMED BY DECADES OF
THE WAR ON DRUGS SPACEY PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
POWER.
ONLY FOR CITIES HAVE A STAB
EQUITY PROGRAM AND NO SUCH
PROGRAM EXIST ON THE STATE LEVEL
FOR TOO MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING EXCLUDED.
FROM THIS GROWING INDUSTRY I
INDUSTRY AGAIN THAT'S ONLY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN EXISTENCE BUT
IT'S PRETTY MUCH 80% WHITE MALE
DOMINATED.
THE MOST URGENT SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES ARE ACCESS TO CAPITAL
LACK OF TECHNICAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND DELIVERY
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THOSE THAT
ARE ALREADY.
PART OF THE INDUSTRY AND THOSE
WHO ARE SEEKING AN ENTRY INTO
THE INDUSTRY UNDER THIS BILL THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL OF
SAYS EQUITY APPLICANTS.
AND LICENSEES IN CONDUCTING
TRAINING AND INFORMATION
SESSIONS ON STATE AND LOCAL
LICENSING PROCESS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY UPON APPROPRIATIONS
OF FUNDING.
ALLOW LOCALITIES TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS TO THE BUREAU WHICH WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT APPLICANTS WITH
REDUCED AND WAVED LICENSING FEES.
THE BUREAU ALSO REQUIRED TO
COLLECT AND REPORT DATA ON
ALLOCATION IN USE OF FUNDING BY
LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAMS AND
DEMOGRAPHICS ON APPLICANTS.
AN INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE TO
MEASURE PROGRAMS OF THE
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS BEEN.
ARE A NATIONAL LEADER.
ON MANY ISSUES THIS IS ANOTHER
AREA WHERE CALIFORNIA CAN GET IT
RIGHT WERE NOT THE FIRST TO DO
THIS BUT BY.
INCLUDING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
MOST IMPACT --
BY PHIL Y. ARE WORN DRUGS WE
HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED.
AS THREE TWELVE NINETY FOUR ONE
COURAGE INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE AND IN
ACCORDANCE TO WHAT THE LAW HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR LOCAL AND
STATE ECONOMIES.
AND WHILE UPLOADING PUBLIC
HEALTH AN IMPROVING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND A REGULATED MARKET I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORK.
ON THIS MEASURE TO REVERSE THE
DAMAGE IMPACTS A CANNABIS
PROHIBITION AND ALSO ADDRESS THE
LARGER ISSUE OF IMPLICIT RACIAL
BIAS THAT EXISTS WITHIN THE
SECTORS OF OUR COMMITTEE --
ECONOMY TODAY WITH ME IS RODNEY
HOLCOMB ATTORNEY FOR THE DRUG
ALLIANCE OUR RESPECT LESS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE TWO
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PERCENT GONNA BE
READY.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
MONEY [inaudible]
TO POLICY ALLIANCE ORGANIZATION
THAT AS CAMPAIGN FOR THE
LEGALIZATION OF MEDICAL AND
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS OVER THE
PAST TWO DECADES ACROSS OUR
NATION.
HOW WE PLAYED A HUGE ROLE IN
DRAFTING IN CAMPAIGNINGAROUND
THE DON'T USE OF MARIJUANA ACT
OR AS WE MORE COMMONLY KNOW IT A
PROP SIXTY FOUR A TODAY I COME
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE CANNABIS
COLLABORATION?
AND INCLUSION ACT YOU KNOW IT'S
ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE HOW WE
ARRIVED AT THIS POINT I STARTED
TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS I
JUST A SHORT WHILE AGO CANNABIS
WAS CRIMINALIZED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WAS ESPECIALLY DEVASTATING
FOR PERSONS OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ARE BUT
SINCE PROP SIXTY FOUR PASSED A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
RECREATIONAL CAN'T BRETT
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
HAS BEEN CREATED IN THE STATE
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITHIN
IT ARE CONSTANTLY DEVELOPING.
UNSURPRISINGLY THOUGH ALLTHESE
OPPORTUNITIES RELEASE ACCESSIBLE
TO PEOPLE --
FROM COMMUNITIES MOST HARMED BY
CANNABIS PROHIBITION ALSO
BECAUSE WE AT THE OUTSET OF THIS
INDUSTRY HOW WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THIS MARKET IS ONE THAT IS BOTH
EQUITABLE AND ACCESSIBLE AYE AND
WHAT S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
CAN I DO FOR US IS THAT CAN
OFFER FOLKS AN OPPORTUNITY.
I LIKE NEVER BEFORE TO SUCCEED
AND AN EMERGING INDUSTRY NOW
MANY LOCALITIES HAVE BEGUN TO
ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS BY
CREATING LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAMS
AND THE STATE IS WELL POSITIONED
TO SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS.
AND TAKE THEM TO THE NEXT LEVEL
I ONE OF THE STATED PURPOSE IS
AN INTENSIVE PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS
ACTUALLY TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
ENTERING OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
AND S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
WILL DO JUST THAT [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I AM
MALACHI AMEND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP.
AND WE'RE A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON BUILDING
ECONOMIC SECURITY IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WE HAVE ORGANIZED OVER
THREE HUNDRED ACTIVIST COMMUNITY.
BUSINESS OF FAITH LEADERS TO TWO
WAY AND ON THE ISSUE OF CANNABIS
EQUITY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO --
IN A NETWORK THAT IS BETTER IS
WORKING WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO STUDY WHERE
MARIJUANA ARRESTS HAVE OCCURRED
IN POPULATIONS OF OVER.
TWENTY THOUSAND AND SO WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS IS STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
YOUR ADOPTION OF THIS MEASURE
WERE STRONGLY SO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE AND WE'D LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR BRADFORD FOR HIS
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO EQUITY --
AND MAKING PATHWAYS FOR COMMIT
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MARGINALIZED WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS JUST MINOR CONCERNS --
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE BILL IN AND
OUT WE WE WOULD LIKE --
TO AT SOME POINT HAVE --
THAT CONSIDERATION OF OF HOW.
THE STATE CAN ESTABLISH PRIORITY
PROCESSING FOR STATE APPLICANTS
FOR CANNABIS BUSINESS LICENSES --
SO THAT THOSE APPLICANTS FOR
CANNABIS BUSINESS LICENSES FROM.
CITIES WITH EQUITY PROGRAMS GET
PRIORITY PROCESSING.
WHERE'S THE STATUS IS IS IT IS
PROCESSING --
APPLICANTS FOR STATE LICENSES.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES REGION'S
BEGIN SUPPORT NAME INFLATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
CHAIRMAN.
AGAIN.
YOU GET YOUR ME MISTER DAVID
JONES OF HALF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE AN EQUITY
PROBLEM FIND IT TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND WE ASK FOR MY
VOTE.
MORNING JASON RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
A CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
ARE ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND MY CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JUST REPRINTING NINE POINT
STRATEGIES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MAX NICHOLSON BAFFLING HOW
FRICKIN WAS DELIVERY ALLIANCE
WE'VE GOT CHAPTERS IN THE BAY
AREA LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO --
ALIVE DELIVERY OPERATORS ARE
EQUITY APPLICANTS WORK IN
PHOTOGRAPH PLEASE WE SUPPORT A
BILL THANK YOU.
ROXANA BACK MOMMY ON BEHALF OF
WE DROP IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA AND MO WAS SHY ORDER
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL O'DONNELL K. HERE WE
HAVE THE CITY OF OF OAKLAND THE
FIRST CITY TO HAVE A EQUITY --
PROGRAM THINK THAT SENATOR VERY
MUCH FOR ALL OF HIS WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRISON BEHALF SEIU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THE BILL.
PRIME BOXES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CAL FOR MINORITY LINES
INLAND EMPIRE CHAPTER AS WELL
SEE HOPE FOR CAL FOR GAMBAS
COALITION WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL ONE THING WE
WOULD LIKE FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND ESPECIALLY IN AREAS
SUCH AS KYLE A WHERE WE WORK
CONTINUOUSLY ESPECIALLY
[inaudible]
RELATION WE NEED TO HAVE A
STATEWIDE FORM FOR EQUITY WHERE
CITY SUCH IS LA WHERE THEY
ALREADY HAVE EQUITY PROGRAM
PRIORITIZE THEIR EQUITY
APPLICANTS BUT THAT MANDATES
OTHER CITIES THAT ARE NOT n
EXUBERANT TO ALLOW FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO TO HAVE A
FIRM FRAMEWORK OF WHICH THE
PARAMETERS FOR THEM TO USE THIS
IS GOING TO BE BASED AROUND.
AND ESPECIALLY THE REMARKS MADE
FOR SPECIALLY BUT LATELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES [inaudible]
OCEANS BE SEEING NO WITNESSES
MACHINISTS BEACH ANY WITNESSES
AND OPPOSITION.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS A MOVE
THE BILL.
OKAY THAT'S BEEN IN MOTION --
SENATOR BRADFORD YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I THINK --
WE'VE HAD A VERY THOROUGH
DISCUSSION ON WHAT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL LIVES SIDE IT'S BEEN
SOME WHO.
WANT -- TO
MISREPRESENT WHAT IT IS BUT THIS
IS ABOUT DIVERSITY THIS IS ABOUT
EQUITY THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND HAVE AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS
GREAT POTENTIAL BUT THAT.
THE TENT YOU SHOULD REFLECT ALL
THE DIVERSE --
COMMUNITIES --
RACES GENDERS AND MAKING SURE
EVERYONE HAS A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD OFTEN STATED WHO WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF MARIJUANA.
THE ROOM WOULD BE FILLED WITH
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE.
BUT NOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
WERE OUT OF THE ROOM THIS
WEEKEND I WAS INVITED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A CONFERENCE IN
LA.
ON SUNDAY AND IT WAS PRIDE THE
MOST DIVERSE --
GROUP BY IT PRESENT IT BEFORE --
JUST TWO WEEKS BEFORE I WASN'T
SACRUM AYE MEANS A SANTA MONICA
AND THE ROOM DIDN'T LOOK THE WAY
IT LOOKED ON SUNDAY.
AND EVERYONE CLEARLY DISCUSSED
THE NEED OF DIVERSITY IT'S BEING
EMBRACED BY AGAIN THE CITY OF LA
I THINK WE CAN LEARN FROM WHAT
THE STATES OF COLORADO WASHING
HAVE DONE AND I THINK WE THE WAY.
ON A DON'T USE --
RECREATION BUT ALSO IN EQUITY
AND AND NOW COOPERATION AND
DIVERSITY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR BRADFORD THIS DOES
AND JOIN AYE RECOMMENDS
DICTATION --
WE NEED A SECOND.
IS THAT BEEN EMOTIONLESS LIKING
THE MUSIC FAIR PLEASE CULTURAL.
RUSSIA'S DE PASSED SEPARATIONS
LOW AYE LOW AYE VOEPEL NO VOEPEL
NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NO GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
ARE NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING. SEVEN AYE A THREE NO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPS
NUMBER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR BRADFORD WHEN I MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AS BE
A FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ.
SIR HERNANDEZ WELCOME PLEASE
VISIT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURZA
THIS BILL FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIRWORK I WOULD BE ACCEPTING
ALL THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL IMPROVES THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY'S ABILITY TO REGULATE
AUTOMATING DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE USE OF
THESE DEVICES FOR DISPENSING
MEDICATION IN A LIMITED SETTINGS
ON THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH A
LICENSING FRAMEWORK TO ALLOW THE
BOARD TO TRACK SUCH DEVICES
ENSURE APPROPRIATE CONTROLS.
ARE BEING FOLLOWED TO PROTECT
PATIENT SAFETY AND ACCESS TO
PHARMACIST CARE THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO EXPAND THE SETTINGS THEY
CAN USE IT AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE
BLUE WE BELIEVE WILL ADDRESS A
HOSPICE CONCERNS.
AND LOOK FOR THE RESOLUTION
NINETY WITH MIA VIRGINIA HERO
FROM THE BOARD OF PHARMACY TO
TEST FINANCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE.
GOOD MORNING I'M VIRGIN HURLED
AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY AND I'D LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR HERNANDEZ FOR
TAKING THIS BILL ON THIS BILL
WILL HELP EIGHT PATIENTS IN
OBTAINING THEIR MEDICATION
OUTSIDE PHARMACIES PARTICULARLY.
CURRENTLY IF YOU WANT TO USE THE
MACHINE LIKE AN AUTOMATIC TELLER
TO OBTAIN YOUR PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS YOU COULD ONLY DO IT
IF THE MACHINE WAS LOCATED
ADJACENT TO THE PHARMACY COUNTER.
THIS IS AN OPT IN PROCESS OF THE
PAGE THE METS WHICH ALLOWS THEM
AFTER HOURS.
TO THEIR MEDICATION IN A WAY
THAT THEY CAN'T DO NOW.
BILL ALSO HAS ANOTHER COMPONENT
THAT --
ALLOWS US TO LICENSE PYXIS
MACHINES WHICH ARE ME MACHINES
USED TO ADMINISTER MEDICATIONS
AND HEALTH CARE SETTINGS IT
PROVIDES FLOOR STOCK ESSENTIALLY
AVAILABLE TO HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS SO THEY CAN
QUICKLY DELIBERATE AND
ADMINISTER.
PATIENTS SO YOU HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU CAN ON A
INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY AND ON
WE'RE GRATEFUL AND ASK THEIR AYE
VOTE.
PETER CALLISON ON BEHALF OF S.
TERRACE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION.
SCARCE IS ONE OF THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE THESE
DEVICES THAT WAS PART OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT GAVE THE IMPETUS FOR THE
LEGISLATION THE HOSPICE
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS INCREASED
ACCESS TO DISPENSING.
THE MEDICATIONS TO THE TURMOIL
THIS BILL DOES EXPAND ACCESS IN
PROVIDING CARE DIRECTLY TO
PATIENTS IN OURS IN SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO DIVISIONAL WIN ASSISTANCE
BOARD ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME TO THAT.
WHERE HE LIKE?
WHETHER YOU LIKE [inaudible]
GOOD.
COUNTY DELGADO WITHA CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DID HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WANTED TO CLARIFY ONE
OF THE THANK THE AUTHOR THE
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION WHEN THE BILL GETS IN
PRINT THINK IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME SEEING NONE
SENATOR HELMS JEWISH TO CLOSE
PAST WHENEVER PLEASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS DOESN'T JOIN AYE
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I'D LOW AYE
VOEPEL AYE AYE VOEPEL AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
I WHEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
TING.
FAMOUS A CHAIR.
THEY DO VERY MUCH THAT HAS
ELEVEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS S. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR FULLER.
SENATOR FULLER WELCOME THIS DOES
INTO AN AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE RELATING TO THE SALE
OF CANNABIS TO MINORS.
THANK YOU LET ME ALSO START BY
SAYING I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE.
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE SIX TO
IMPOSE A MINIMUM PENALTY
STANDARD ON ANY LICENSEE WHO
CELLS ARE PERNICIOUS CANNABIS OR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO A PERSON
UNDER THE LEGAL AGE.
THE BUREAU OF CANADA'S CONTROLS
PRESENTLY AUTHORIZED TO SUSPEND
OR REVOKE A LICENSE FOR ANY ACT
CONSTITUTING GROUNDS FOR
DISCIPLINARY ACTION INCLUDING
ILLEGAL CANNABIS SALES.
IN DETERMINING WHAT PENALTY TO
IMPOSE IN A GIVEN CASE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL MAY CONSIDER A
MULTITUDE OF FACTORS.
THE BUREAU RECENTLY ADOPTED
GUIDELINES TO PROMOTE
CONSISTENCY AND DISCIPLINARY
ORDERS AGAINST CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE VIOLATED
THE LAW.
HOWEVER DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS
TAKEN AT THE BUREAU'S DISCRETION.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE GOES
BEYOND THE BUREAU'S GUIDELINES
BY STATUTORILY MANDATING A
FIFTEEN DAY SUSPENSION FOR THE
FIRST VIOLATION.
AND REVOCATION FOR THIRD
VIOLATION OCCURRING ON THE SAME
PREMISES WITHIN THIRTY SIX
MONTHS.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE DOES
NOT PROHIBIT THE BUREAU FROM
REVOKING A LICENSE PRIOR TO THE
THIRD VIOLATION.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THESE ARE THE MINIMUM
PENALTIES TO BE IMPOSED AND DO
NOT PRECLUDE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS TO BE TAKEN
BY THE BUREAU FOR THESE ACTS.
MEMBERS AS THE AVAILABILITY AND
THE POTENCY OF PRODUCTS.
CANNABIS PRODUCTS CONTINUES TO
INCREASE OUR CHILDREN OUR
GREATEST RISK.
IF YOU LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
STUDIES COMING OUT A COLORADO
YOU SAW THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY THINK NOW THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE DONE WAS WORKED
HARDER ESPECIALLY ON EDIBLE.
PRODUCTS FOR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY HAD A VERY BIG PROBLEM ADAM.
INITIALLY AND THEY'RE WORKING ON
TIGHTENING THOSE REGULATIONS NOW.
SO IF WE CAN WORK ON SAVING OUR
CHILDREN A LITTLE MORE DISTILLED
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS SCHOOL
TEACHER JUST CAN'T RESIST ASKING
YOU TODAY.
THEN S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
SEEKS TO PREVENT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF CANNABIS TO
MINORS.
BY DETERRING RETAILERS FROM
MAKING ILLEGAL UNDER AGE SALES
AND ENSURES THAT COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS ARE MAINTAINED.
BY AN ACTING MINIMUM PENALTY
STANDARDS FOR ENGAGING IN THESE
ACTIVITIES I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEM NO INNOCENT PART ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
TEAM NO QUESTION THE COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME OF
THIS DOESN'T JOIN AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND THAT'S BEEN
IN MOTION AND A SECOND.
COMMITTEE SECTOR WHICH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
RUSSIA'S DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW AYE
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
AND THAT HAD CURRENTLY HAS TEN
VOTES WILL BE THE RULE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SINFUL OF WILL NOW MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY CENTER
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR BUT
SENATE OF IRAQ WELCOME THIS DOES
ALSO ENJOYED I AYE
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE FEEL FREE
PRESENT IN EVERY READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LAST YEAR CONSTITUENT
MINE CAME TO MY DISTRICT OFFICE
ASKING FOR ME TO INTRODUCE A
BILL TO STREAMLINE.
THE TRUCKING LICENSE FOR
VETERANS AFTER RESEARCHING THE
ISSUE MY STAFF EVENTUALLY
DISCOVERED THIS WAS ALREADY LAW.
THE MANY VETERANS WERE UNAWARE.
WE LEARNED THAT SINCE MANY
BETTER BETTER IN SEPARATE FROM
FROM THE SERVICE IN OTHER STATES
THERE ARE AWARE OF ALL THE
BENEFITS ALREADY GIVEN TO THEM
BY CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY MOVE
HOME.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN CLOSES
HIS INFORMATION GAP AND WILL
INFORM VETERANS AND THEIR
SPOUSES OF ALL THE LICENSING
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA OFFERS
THROUGH COMMUNICATION CHANNELS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED.
SUCH AS DEPARTMENTS WEBSITE AND
DISCHARGE INFORMATION PACKETS
GIVEN TO VETERANS WHICH MEANS
THAT.
THREE REPRESENTS MAYBE THE
BETTER GROUPS OR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
TRACKING A CHAIR MEMBERS MINUS
AT THREE POINT THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
[inaudible]
COUNSEL CHAPTERS.
VIETNAM VETERANS ASSOCIATION.
AMERICA ALL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
WHERE?
WITH ME SERVICE MEMBERS
RETURNING FROM OTHER STATES IT
IS VITAL FOR CALIFORNIA ENHANCE
IMPROVE OUR REACHED VETERANS
REGARDING EMPLOYMENT. FOR
EXAMPLE A COMBAT VETERAN TO
COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS.
WAS ENTERING THE ARMY WHEN I
CAME BACK TO CALIFORNIA THERE IS
LITTLE.
INFORMATION THAT WAS EASILY VERY
READILY AVAILABLE FOR ME TO FIND.
TO LOOK FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
SO I COULD SENATE SENATORS
COMMENTS THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEMED AWARENESS IS
AN OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
THE EMOTIONAL ASK YOUR ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR THIS
ALSO DOESN'T JOINT I
RECOMMENDATION.
COMMITTEE SIX VERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DID PASTOR PREPARATIONS
LOW I'D WELL I VOEPEL ROCK
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
FONG I GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES OUT
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN TRAPS
MEMBER THAK YOU ABOUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS AS WE THAN OF WEIGHT FOR
THE OUR FINAL AUTHOR WILL GO
BACK THROUGH THE ROLE.
I WILL START OFF WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS A BE.
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
THIS ITEM MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE COLORFUL.
SENATE AMENDMENTS SHALL BE
CONCURRENT AND LOW HIGH LOW AYE
VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
TING.
AND THAT BILL HAS NINE VOTES
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NOW ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS S. B.. THREE ELEVEN WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THE MOTION SECOND COMMITTEE
THANKS VERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
LOW AYE AYE LOW AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OVER THE TING.
AND THAT HAS NINE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OF ONE THEN GO BACK TO
OUR BILLS HEARD IN FIVE ORDER.
AND CENTER TO HILL WELCOME OF IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO SENATE HELL
WE'RE GOING FILE ORDER THAT
WORKERS ARE YOU BEST WONDERFUL
THANK YOU VERY HOT ITEM --
THIRTEEN S. B. O. FOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND SUMMERHILL AS YOU KNOW --
ALL THREE OF YOUR BILLS HAVE A
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
FILTHY TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY WELL VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES IT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD TO STUDY WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD BENEFIT FROM
RECEIVING CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS
SETTLEMENT. FOR THEIR LICENSES
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN ARE TRICKY ASTRONAUT VOTE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS A AND JUST AS THE A
CLARIFICATION THAT THAT ALSO GET
ACCEPTING THE AMEND ITS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU LIKE --
ADDITIONAL --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON IS IS IT
AND SO --
WILL ALLOW UP. TO TWO MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
AND WELCOME.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO ME READY.
I'M SURE YOU REMEMBER ME FROM
LAST WEEK.
SUCH I MAKE IT PRETTY FAST I'M
JACKI DOT WHO BEGAN AND I AM THE
MOTHER OF ACTUALLY DONE HIM.
AGAIN TO BOLIVIA BURKE WHO WAS
KILLED IN THE BERKELEY BALCONY
COLLAPSE ON JUNE SIXTEENTH --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AS A SAID
BEFORE MCGEORGE OF OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD TO PASS
LEGISLATION.
BUT NOT HEARING CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL BILL FOR
SIXTY FIVE IS WATERED DOWN.
BECAUSE OF THE LOBBYISTS.
AND THE REPORTING STRUCTURE WAS
TAKEN OPTION AND IT WASN'T FOR
STUDY.
SO THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE BILL UP TO STUDY.
BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU GUYS IS
HOW WOULD YOU.
ARE ALL THE PEOPLE LIVING OF
BALCONIES KNOW IF THEY WERE SAFE
ARE JUST WAITING TO FALL DOWN.
IF THE STUDENTS HAD I KNOWN THAT
SAKE WE HAD ISSUES WITH
BALCONIES ABID SUED REPEATEDLY
OVER THE PAST DECADE BY CLAIMS
OF SHODDY WORK AND PAID OUT OVER
TWENTY SIX MILLION.
IN THE TREE YEARS PART TO
BERKELEY BALCONY CLAPPED BECAUSE
OF WATER DAMAGE.
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE THE
STUDENTS WOULD BE ON THAT
BALCONY.
I DON'T THINK SO.
WHAT THAT SEGUE BUILT WOULD YOU
I WENT OUT ON THE BALCONY?
WHY IS THE COMPANY ALLOWED TO
SHODDY WORK AND THEN SECRETLY
PAID TO COVER UP?
WHY IS THE CONTRACTORS ARE
DIFFERENT TO PHYSICIANS
ENGINEERS ARCHITECTS?
BUT OUR PROFESSIONALS ARE
REQUIRED TO NOTIFY STATE
LICENSING BOARD WHEN THEY SETTLE
LAWSUITS.
STEAMING FROM WORK RELATED
ERRORS WHY SHOULD THE PUBLIC AND
THE REGULATORS BE KEPT OUT OF
THE LOOP ON THE CONTRACTOR
SETTLEMENT RIGHT COURTS.
S. B. ONE FOUR SIX FIVE IS MUCH
NARROWER THAN SELF REPORTING AN
INSURER REPORT LAWS.
THAT I NEED OR LICENSEE TRADE
AND PROFESSION.
ITS REPORT REQUIREMENT IS JUST A
MILLION DOLLARS AND APPLIES
HOMEY TO MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL STRUCTURES SOME
HOTELS COLLEGES.
AND SINGLE FAMILY HOMES GUYS ARE
NOT INCLUDE IT.
SO REALLY.
IT SADDENS ME THE PEOPLE OPPOSE
THIS BECAUSE IT CAN PREVENT
MAJOR IN JUST YEAR DEFT.
AND DIS GROUP SHOULD WANT TO
RESERVE REPRESENT A SAFE
INDUSTRY AND STOP HIDING BEHIND
BACK CONTRACTORS BY SUPPORTING
THE CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD
CAN GET RID OF UP BY DOCTORS.
I'M BY ALLOWING SETTLEMENTS FROM
INSURANCE ARE CONSTRUCTION
COMPANIES TO BE FORWARD TO THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD SO
THEY CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
BY A CONFIDENTIAL INVESTIGATION
SUCH CONFIDENTIAL THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ASKING.
FOR WHAT YOU THINK IT WAS YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL?
MANY MANY MORE BALCONIES GOING
TO FALL DOWN IN CALIFORNIA.
I JUST MY LAST POINT REVIEW AS
MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC IS
REQUIRED TO BE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR THE CONTRACTORS
LICENSING BOARDS. TO REALLY
EXERCISE ITS LICENSING
REGULATORY AND DISPLAY INJURY
FUNCTIONS.
HOW CAN THE CONTRACTORS
LICENSING BOARD DO THEIR JOB A
PROTECT THE PUBLIC IF THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE TOOLS?
RIGHT NOW THEY'VE RECEIVED ABOUT.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS PER YEARS BUT THEY'RE
ALL SINGLE FAMILY.
THEY'RE NOT THE BIG MULTI.
THEY DON'T GET MUCH RELATED TO
MULTI DWELLINGS SINCE THEY'VE
SETTLED OUT OF COURT ARE SUBTLE
AND THE INSURANCE MAKE THE
PAYMENTS.
SO THE CONTEXT LINES WERE NEVER
FIND OUT ABOUT IT LIKE IN
SIDEWAYS CASE SO IS THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD ONLY
DARE TO PROTECT SINGLE FAMILY --
RELATED CONSUMER COMPLAINTS.
GUYS THIS IS A A REASON TO
REFORM THE DESERVES TO BE MOVE
FORWARD.
TO AND TO REALLY PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AND THE VISITORS
I'M SPEAKING OUT TODAY IN HONOR
OF THE STUDENTS HERE.
AT THE PICTURES LOOK AT THEM
FRONT TO ME --
WHO NO LONGER HAVE A VOICE?
I URGE YOU GUYS TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND DON'T LET THEIR DEATHS
BE IN VAIN.
ITS MY QUEST TO BRING ABOUT
CHANGE TO PREVENT SUCH A MEDIA
STRATEGY FROM REOCCURRING
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF ELSE HAD DONE
THE RIGHT THING.
AND THERE'S NO SECRET
SETTLEMENTS PAID OUT BY SEGWAY
IN CHURNS AND THE CONSTRUCTION
BOARD HADN'T KNOWN ABOUT THIS.
PEACE KIDS COULD HAVE BEEN ALIVE
TODAY.
THEY COULD BE TODAY HAVE MUCH.
HOW DIFFERENT REPORT TO DO SO
THE CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE IMPORTS
BECAUSE STATEWIDE HAD PAID OUT
SO MANY MILLIONS THREE YEARS
PRIOR [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WE NO AND DO THE RIGHT TO AND
I'M VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
IF THE PARENTS I DON'T CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THE BUILDER LOBBYISTS CARE ABOUT
MY DAUGHTER MY KNEES AT THE FOUR
FRIENDS WHO DIED BUT BURKE YOU
DON'T NEED TO UPS.
AND THE SEVEN WHO WERE SERIOUSLY
INJURED.
BUT FAIR ABOUT THE PUBLIC THAT'S
WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
AND YOU THE LAWMAKERS SHOULD.
TO SO I'M REALLY ASKING YOU HEAR
ME TODAY HOW MY PUNK YOU KNOW
TIME.
COULD YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY AND A
DISH NO WITNESSES SO WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEE NO DISH NO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EPIDIDYMIS DE ANY ADDITIONAL IF
YOU COULD CUT GET KIND THE US
SUBMARINES APOLOGIES --
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE AND THAT HE
FOR THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- ONE
OF OUR CORE MISSION THIS REMOVAL
OF BAD ACTORS FROM THE INDUSTRY
WHEN NECESSARY AND WE BELIEVE
THAT CSV EFFECTIVENESS IN HAND
FROM THE PUBLIC IS ABLE TO
REPORT POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF
THE CONTRACTORS LAW. TO THE
CONTRACTORS BOARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
HOT BLOOM STEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN RELUCTANT
OPPOSITION TO BE VERY BRIEF.
OUR OPPOSITION IS IS THIS A
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY BELIEVE THAT --
CIVIL SETTLEMENTS ARE INDICATORS
OF FAULTY WORK IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY AN INDICATION OF
FAULTY WORK.
AND TO ILLUSTRATE THAT POINT TO
THE THE BURDEN OF PROOF
STANDARDS ARE DIFFERENT FOR CS
OB DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS.
THE STANDARD IS CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE OF FOR CIVIL
ACTIONS IT'S A PREPONDERANCE OF
THE EVIDENCE THERE'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
DID DIFFERENT STANDARDS THAT ARE
RECESS WE DON'T THINK THE
INFORMATION TO THE BOARD IS
GONNA NECESSARILY INDICATE
FAULTY WORKING FINALLY.
OF THE CIVIL SETTLEMENTS ARE NOT
MADE BY CONTRACTORS THEY'RE MADE
BY THE INSURANCE CARRIERS ALSO
BASED ON THOSE TWO REASONS WE DO
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS A COME UP
INSIDE SOMEWHERE MCCARTY THANK
YOU I KNOW THIS IS PART OF A
PACKAGE YOU'RE WORKING ON AND
THEN YOU KNOW MYSELF AND MISTER
GIBSON HAD A CHANCE.
TO MEET WITH SOME OF THE
FAMILIES IN IRELAND TWO YEARS
AGO SO THANK YOU. FOR FOR
CONTINUING ON THE ON THIS
QUESTION AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
UNREASONABLE WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
ITS INFORMATION FOR THAT
CONSUMER.
LIKE PEOPLE DO WHEN THEY GO ON
YELP THESE DAYS THEY WANT TO
GATHER AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HIRE THIS
CONTRACTOR I THINK IT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF DISCLOSURE.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
TO SUPPORT YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM KEY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE TO SENATOR
AGAIN --
THING TO LAST TIME ALSO THINK
THE WITNESS FOR HER TESTIMONY --
AND AS MR MCCARTY INDICATED WAS
A ALSO IN IRELAND AND MET --
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF THOSE
YOUNG INDIVIDUALS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES HERE AND CERTAINLY THERE'S
A MOTIVATION TO TRY TO CORRECT
THAT MAKING SURE THAT.
OF THIS NEVER HAPPENS TO ANYONE
MOVING FOR ONE THANK THE SENATOR
FOR ONE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA.
AND DOM UNDERSTAND THAT MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN ALREADY ILB
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMES FROM
COULD MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE SENATOR HELD YOU
HAVE TO CLICK RECREATION I WILL
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH --
SENATOR JOHN AS YOU --
ARE WELL AWARE ARE GRADUALLY
COMMITTEES WILL ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS IN THE NEXT YEAR WITH
RESPECT TO THE SUNSET AND ASSESS
THE USEFULNESS OF OF SUCH
EFFORTS AND THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
PERFORATIONS LOW AYE AYE THOUGH
I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
WHEN MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHILLS
CUNNINGHAM?
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
GIPSON BY GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I TING.
THE BILL HAS A THIRTEEN AYE
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WITNESSES BOTH IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION SENATOR HILL ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IS THE SUNSET BILL
FOR THE DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
RESPECT WE HAVE FOR I'VE OF
MEMBERS WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
BY SUMMER GIPSON PLEASE UP TO
TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHATEVER IT.
JANET L. WITH AARON READ AN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S DECIDE OR
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
JOANNE GALLIANO JUST TO
INTRODUCE HER FOR ALSO MAY HAVE
A CD AJ.
MY NAME IS FRANK TAGLIANO
NAPROXEN REGISTER DUMPED IN A
HIGH TENANTS FROM WITH AND I HAVE REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA HIGH DISSOCIATION.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THE SPELL AND I'M
AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNING THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
I'M ANTHONY LEMON THE DEBT THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE DENTAL
HYGIENE COMMITTEE.
AND ONE THANK SENATOR HILL AND
STAFF FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL
FOR US.
AND AS YOU KNOW ALL THE CA
PROGRAMS GOING THERE SINCE IT
REVIEW OF YOUR FORTY FIVE YEARS
TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I'LL HOPEFULLY YOU APPROVE OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS --
IN OVERSEEING THE DENTAL HYGIENE
APPLICATION APPLICANTS --
HOT LICENSEES AND EDUCATE.
THIS BILL EXPENSE EXTEND THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF THE DENTAL
HYGIENE COMMITTEE IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEAMAN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND THE NOSE UP TO
TWO MINUTES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT MANEUVER READY.
MARY MCCANN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION AYE WE'RE
ACTUALLY HERE TO SACCO OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
AND NOT NECESSARILY IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT --
FIRST OF ALL WE'VE ENJOYED I
AGREE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DEEP
SEA SEE --
AND ALSO THEIR RELATIONSHIP BUT
THAT ON BOARD OVER THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS AND FEEL THAT WAY.
DE STATUTES AND REGULATIONS --
SPELL OUT RIGHT NOW REALLY
REFLECTS THE DO YOU THE GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP AND
INTERDEPENDENCE OF THE DENTAL
TEAM AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW.
AND FEEL THAT --
ANY CONCERNS AT HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL --
WE STILL FAIL TO SEE THAT THE
PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE SEEKING TO
FIND A SOLUTION.
TO A SPECIFICALLY AROUND THEM
THE NAME CHANGES --
WE WE FIND THAT ANYTHING THAT
THEY'VE --
THAT HAS BEEN SAID IN THE THE
COMMITTEE REPORT AROUND
CONFUSION AROUND THE NAME.
I THINK REALLY ATTRIBUTES OF THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER CITY IN
THE COUNTRY AND THAT IT HAS.
ITS OWN REGULATORY ENTITY FOR
DENTAL HYGIENE AND NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE IT'S CALLED
A COMMITTEE OR BOARD.
WE FEEL LIKE THE CONFUSION
AROUND THAT WOULD STILL EXIST.
DESPITE THE NAME CHANGE TO A
BOARD BUT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS SEEING NONE
ANY QUESTIONS CONSTANTLY MEMBERS
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
SEGMENT HELP YOU WISH TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK TRIBE MEMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMEY
CYCLICALLY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS LOW I KNOW I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA REPLY BAKER
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTY VOTES WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
IN OUR TO OUR FINAL BILL FOR
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAREST BE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS THE BUREAU OF
ELECTRONIC AN APPLIANCE REPAIR
HOME FURNISHINGS ANDTHERMAL
INSULATION IS.
SUNSET BILL OR SHORTLY AFTER AND
I BOTH THANK YOU WONDERFUL
THANKS VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEN THAT ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SAYING.
NINE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
CALAVERAS AT THIS TIME SING THEN
AT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND CAN BE SAID FOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH IS THE PAST APPROPRIATIONS
LOW HIGH LOW AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL
AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER BAKER AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN.
BERMAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN AYE VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
FIELDER AND REALLY ISN'T
PRESENTATIONS MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MEMBERS WE'VE NOW HAVE.
HAD ALL PRESENTATION OF BILLS
WILL GO THROUGH --
FILE ORDER WHICH IS AT ONE
MOMENT.
LET'S FIRST GO TO CONSENT
CALENDAR WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
MOTION IS THINKING THROUGH
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. SEVEN SIXTY TAIL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO PASS AS
AMENDED.
IN RE REFER TO PREPARATIONS WITH
RICK RECOMMENDATION TO CONSULT
LOW.
BUT I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ARAMBULA.
BUT MY CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON GRAYSON HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN BERMAN AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE AROUND A OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible] FIFTY VOTES.
PAST CONSENT --
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE AND REMEMBER
WHAT -- BACK
IN FOLLOW ORDER AND MEMBERS WILL
GO AND HOW ORDER FOR STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS SHALL BE CONCURRENT
AND BAKER.
MEMBERS WERE IN THE FILE ITEM WE
ARE NUMBER.
ONE BAKER I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. THREE
ELEVEN BY SENATOR PAT.
MUST DE PASSED AS AMENDED BAKER.
BAKER I CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S. B. SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR GALGIANI.
MY SISTER PASSED AS IN THE NATO
PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I CHILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THAT SEVENTEEN DESERVE THE BILL
IS OUT.
OF MOVING ON TO I'LL ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. NINE THIRTY HERTZBERG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MUCHAS DE PASS APPROPRIATIONS
LOW.
NO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NO GIPSON.
IF I GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE AYE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
OKAY SO EARLY WE DID NOT HAVE A
MOTION ON THAT BILL SO I'LL TAKE
A MOTION ON SB NINE THIRTY
HERTZBERG.
THAT I THINK THERE WILL MOTION
AND A SECOND CAN YOU SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLLED WOULD CALL AGAIN.
OKAY COLOR AGAIN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
I OF VOEPEL CHANGING US TO NOW
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NO GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MON I OBERNOLTE ARE A LOT AYE
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
DEBTS THIRTEEN TO TO THE BILL IS
OUT.
FILE ITEMS SIX SP AT NINE THIRTY
SEVEN WINNER AND LEYVA MADAM
SECRETARY THE WE NEED A MOTION
OKAY.
THE MOTION ON SB.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN COME ON A
SECOND [inaudible]
OKAY.
MATTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DAY PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
VOEPEL NO VOEPEL NOW ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BIGGER NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHUN.
GEN NO JOKE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
I MEAN I FONG.
FONG NOW GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE NO
OBERNOLTE NOTING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
STAND FOR THE BILL IS OUT
.
THEY FILE ITEM SETTLEMENT SEVEN
S. B. NINE NINE NINE MORALE
MEMBERS OCCUR PLEASE FEDERAL.
MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOW [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NOW MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN NOTING [inaudible]
TING NOW. TO CATCH THREE TO
ELEVEN WERE TO HOLD THE RULE
OPEN ON THAT BILL.
PREGNANT WOMEN NOW.
MAKE THAT.
THREE TO TWELVE FILING A MATE SP
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN FIVE ACT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED HER
PREPARATIONS BAKER.
BAKER I CHILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
EGGMAN AYE.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
WHEN I IRWIN?
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I OBERNOLTE MY OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
PLAY THE CAT SIXTEEN IS THERE
WERE LIBERAL OPEN ON THAT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINE S. B.
[inaudible]
TWELVE SEVENTEEN THEIR MOTION.
OKAY AS A MOTION ARCHITECT THAT
IS A SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AS BECAUSE SEVENTEEN MOTIONS YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER I BLEW.
BLOOM AYE CHAN [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OVERLOOKING AYE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
DETAILS FOURTEEN TO ZERO
RELIEVED ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN SP
TWELVE NINETY FOUR BRADFORD
[inaudible]
THEIR MOTION.
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
OKAY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MY SISTER PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
TO GIPSON [inaudible]
GIPSON.
IT'S NOT VOTING [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
A BILL TO NOTING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
GIPSON MOVE FOR NOT VOTING TO
VOTING AYE.
THERE THE CARE WAS TWELVE BEFORE
WE LEAVE ROLE OPEN ON THAT FOR
ITS MEMBERS.
MOVING A FILE ITEM ELEVEN S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN HERNANDEZ
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUSH HAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE ABILITY AYE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
TING AYE.
YOU THE CARE SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
WERE TO HOLD THE RULE OPEN ON
THAT FOR ITS MEMBERS.
PHYLUM TWELVE S. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE FULLER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MY SISTER PASSED AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS BAKER.
BAKER I CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE AYE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING TING AYE. TO
IT DATA SEVENTEEN TO ZERO REALLY
THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE HELL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MUCH AS YOU PATH AS MANAGER OF
OPERATIONS CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG [inaudible]
FONG NUMBERING [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
IT YOU HAVE SIXTEEN ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN ON THAT.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
JOSEPH ANTI ZERO WOULD HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ON THAT.
FINALLY A FILE ITEM FIFTEEN S.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MUCH AS YOUR PASTOR PREPARATIONS
CHAU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
I BEHIND.
A CAT SEVENTY TWO ZERO HOLD THE
ROLE BUT ON THAT
.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA ROLL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE AGAIN A START
WITH FILE ITEM ONE A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE AMENDED SHALL BE
CONCURRED AND CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE. SEVENTY TWO ZERO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FILE ITEM TO
SP THREE ELEVEN PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BUSH IS TO PASS AS A MENDOCINO.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE. SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FILE
ITEM THREE SB SEVEN EIGHTY TO
HERNANDEZ MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND WRAPPED IN IN RE
REFER TO PREPARATIONS RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT.
EGGMAN.
I MEAN I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
DATE SEVENTEEN ZERO OVER OPEN ON
THAT FILE ITEM FOR S. B. SEVEN
NINETY FIVE GALGIANI THEM
GALGIANI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
WHILE I'M FIVE THAT WERE HOLDEN
ROLE OPEN ON FINAL ITEM FOR
FILING FIVE S. B. NINE THIRTY
HERTZBERG MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTIONS YOU PASS
APPROPRIATIONS GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
IT'S FOURTEEN TO TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ON THAT FILE ITEM SIX
S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN WIENER
IN LEYVA MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
CHIU CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AVERTING.
ATTEND A FOR WILDER WROTE ROLL
OPEN ON THAT FILE ITEM SEVEN SP
NINE NINE NINE MORALE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
CHIU CUNNINGHAM. THREE TWELVE OR
ALL THE ROLL OPEN ON THAT FILE
ITEM EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN BIDAK MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS YOU PAST UP OPERATIONS
CHIU CUNNINGHAM GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE. SEVENTEEN TO ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FILE
ITEM NINE S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN
MORALE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS A MANAGER OF
OPERATIONS CHEN [inaudible]
CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
IT'S FOURTEEN TO ZERO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN [inaudible]
THE WATSON.
WHERE ARE PAUSE FOR JUST A
MOMENT AND THEN WE'LL START OVER
FROM THE TOP OF THE ROLE
?
WE ARE GOING TO RUN THROUGH THE
ITEMS UP FOR MEMBERS.
TO AT ON THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE AMENDMENTS SHALL BE
CONCURRED AND CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU I AND FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO S. B. THREE ONE ONE DO PASS
AS AMENDED CUNNINGHAM.
COMING IN MY FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE CONSENT CALENDAR DE HOUSE
AS MEN AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
PREPARATIONS WITH RECOMMENDATION
TO CONSENT CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CAN I FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR S. B. SEVEN NINETY FIVE DO
NOT AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE SB NINE THIRTY TWO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.. FIVE AND SIX AS
ME NEITHER SEVENTY PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING I'M NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN S. B. NINE NINE NINE DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM NOW [inaudible]
FILE ITEM.
SB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN DEPARTURE
PREPARATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP I AND FILE ITEM.
NINE S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I..
WELL AND NUMBER.
TEN S. B. TWELVE MONEY FOR TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING IN NOW.
FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING IN MY FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE DEFENSE AS AN INITIAL
PREPARATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP NOTING.
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN S. BE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO TO PASS AS A MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING AYE.
AND FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP I
THIS IS AN AMONG
ITEM NUMBER.
NINE S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO
PASS AS AMENDED OPERATIONS
ARAMBULA AYE ARAMBULA AYE
.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN JONES SAWYER.
SENATE MITCHELL BEACON CARD AND
CHU.
CHU AYE.
BUT I JIM IS THERE THE BILL'S
OUT FILE AND WERE TO S. B..
THREE ELEVEN DO PASS AS AMENDED.
CHU CHU AYE. NINETEEN OH THAT
BILL IS OUT.
S. B. SEVEN STE SIXTY TWO WAS
EARLY ON CONSENT --
ACTUALLY I'M TO CONSENT THAT
SUMMIT YOU [inaudible] TWO I
PAST THE SP SEVEN NINETY FIVE
GALGIANI. TO PASS AS AN ADDITIVE
OPERATIONS CHAU CHIU AYE.
NINETEEN OH THAT BILL IS OUT.
S. B..
NINE THIRTY THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LOW.
AYE LOW AYE.
CHU CHU AYE. SEVENTEEN TO TO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
S. B..
NINE THIRTY SEVEN THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS LOW ARE LOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE.
TOLD TO FOR THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
S. B.. NINE NINE NINE BY SENATOR
MORROW.
DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS CHU.
CHU NOW. 321-4 THAT BILL FAILS.
S. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN DO PASS OF
CHU CHU AYE. NINETEEN THOUGH
THAT BILL IS OUT.
IS BE TWELVE SEVENTEEN BY CENTER
MORRELL.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHU.
CHU AYE [inaudible]
I IN LOW AYE LOW AYE.
IT SEEMED ó THAT BILL IS OUT.
S. B. 1294% OR BRADFORD.
THE PAST APPROPRIATIONS CHU CHU
AYE. THIRTEEN FIVE THE BILL IS
OUT.
THE FORTUNE FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU [inaudible]
JOE I NINETEEN OH THAT BILL IS
OUT.
S. B. FORTUNE FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR FULLER. TO PASS AS A
MONITOR PATIENTS JOB. TO AYE
NINETEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
S. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HILL. TO PASS AS A
MANITOBA RATIONS JOB
[inaudible]
CHIU AYE. SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
S. BE FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR HILL.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO OPERATIONS
CHU.
CHU AYE NINETEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
CENTER TO HELP. TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
[inaudible]
CHIU AYE. NINETEEN OH THAT BILL
IS OUT.
GOOD WE ARE HERE